I try so hard.
Boom.
And we're live Hamilton Morris sober as
fuck.
How about you?
Absolutely.
Say yes this time.
So we did a podcast seven years ago and
most people apparently didn't know how
fucked up we were,
but uh,
I figured,
damn,
we're here with Hamilton Morris.
We should go deep.
And we just kept hitting that joint
until I lost most of my grasp on reality
while we're talking.
It's just a very slippery conversation.
I was just too high to form coherent
thoughts.
It was just whatever I pieced together
was just a,
you know,
it was almost like miming a
conversation,
but now seven years later and you have a
new place.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
Well you were at the early days.
We did it at my house.
Yeah,
that was way,
way,
way back in the day.
I had no idea really.
I knew you were of course,
but I didn't know about your podcast
entirely.
I'd seen clips of you on youtube and it
wasn't until I was driving home from
that recording and my phone just filled
with hundreds of emails that I realized,
Oh wow,
this is a serious phenomenon that I was
not aware of and now I see.
It's just become huge.
It's a weird thing,
dude.
It,
it's a,
it's got the wheel.
I just sort of have to show up.
It's a very strange and it sounds like,
um,
false modesty or something like that,
but I'm just being totally honest,
like this thing does itself.
I think a lot of it might have to do
with the long form because people are so
used to seeing people's opinions
condensed and filtered into these
soundbites and snippets and to hear an
extended conversation with someone where
they can actually tell stories and
articulate their opinions and a nuanced
careful ways.
So rare.
I agree.
It's one of the reasons why I don't do
those shows anymore,
like panel shows and things like that.
It's just so frustrated.
It's insane.
I have very little experience with that
sort of thing,
but I did Dr Oz last year.
Yes.
And I don't know how any normal person
could function and that sort of
environment.
I mean,
I have a TV show,
so arguably I'm well trained for that
sort of thing,
but unless you're an actor who's
prepared a line to say,
as soon as they point at you,
there's no way that you could function
because it's not a genuine conversation.
It's just an opportunity to launch one
sentence,
sound bites and an audience applause.
And also the audience is such a strange
element to add to a conversation.
I mean,
if you and I were having this
conversation exactly in this room,
but to the left of us is an enormous
group of people.
We've feel weird.
We'd have to address them,
we'd have to turn to them.
It would be odd following illuminated
applause and laughter signs.
God.
Those are the weirdest.
When there's always the warmup guys
like,
okay,
we're ready.
We're coming back from break coming back
from Craig and they hold up the sign and
applause,
applause.
And everybody goes crazy.
And the create the worst environment.
I was on this,
uh,
discussion about [inaudible].
Are you familiar with this?
I'm on it right now.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I just took some.
I,
I fucked my knee up the other day.
I did something and it's been stiff and
painful.
So I used it before I came here and then
I just took,
took six of them.
See what happens.
Wow.
10 ones.
10.
One gram.
I don't know how much.
I don't know.
Can you grab that bag?
There's a bag that's sitting right on
the sink.
I'll tell you exactly what's in it.
But uh,
now I get why people might think it's a
drug.
What is the drug?
Yeah,
for sure.
But when I took four,
I was like,
well,
I took two for the first time I took it.
I took two and a couple of times I took
to him.
Look,
this is like a mild stimulant,
but then when you get into the range of
eight to 10 pills,
it's like,
oh,
this,
this will fuck you up.
This stuff.
The stuff I take is urban ice organics
and um,
see it says,
it says take two.
It doesn't say the amount of material in
the capsule was say 750 milligrams.
Okay,
so not quite a gram,
not quite a gram.
All right.
It seems like a reasonable amount,
but they always construct these things
in these ridiculous dramatic
oppositions.
Like it was me versus a woman whose son
had died of some Creton associated
overdose,
and it turns into a thing like,
well,
what do you have to say to this woman
whose son died?
And it's like,
I don't know.
You know,
there are people that die from caffeine
overdoses as well.
It's tragic that this happened.
How people died from this.
Yes.
They have to have to take an enormous
amount.
I mean,
I think a lot of people set up these
unrealistic expectations with these
drugs where they,
if they'd like a drug,
they want to say it's impossible for it
to kill anyone.
It's impossible.
There's no possible way.
If you set that as your standard,
you'll always fail because people will
die doing absolutely everything.
Running,
having sex deprecating aspirin,
aspirin.
Absolutely.
There's nothing in this world that can't
find its way into a human death.
So if people want to say,
and even you know,
cannabis,
obviously people say you can't overdose
on cannabis and essentially you can't.
But if you look in the medical
literature,
there are a number of these cannabis
associated fatalities.
You know,
you can debate them endlessly,
but the point is,
once a drug enters a large enough
population,
there'll be a number of sensitive
individuals and someone will die.
It doesn't mean that the drug is
dangerous.
It means that it's unrealistic to set a
standard where if anything bad happens
to anyone,
we have to decide that the drug is
dangerous and should be banned.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean,
look,
water kills people.
There's a lot of these hazing things
where the fraternity kids will be asked
to drink a shit ton of water and Oh
yeah,
people have died from it.
A woman died in San Jose a few years
back from a,
a contest to drink water,
get her son like an xbox or something
like that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
there's a lot of things that are lethal,
but the ld 50 for cannabis,
I mean,
you literally have to smoke your body
weight or something.
Right.
It's something crazy would be very
difficult,
you know,
but it doesn't mean that you couldn't
get so high that you did something
really stupid wind up dying.
Right?
Yeah.
Especially dependent upon the person and
the biological variability.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
And it's just.
I think it's also just as sort of a bad
road to go down.
People always want to emphasize the
safety of things,
but in my opinion,
safety isn't the point.
It doesn't ultimately matter to me
whether or not something is safe.
I think we should have the freedom to do
dangerous things if we choose.
We're allowed to ride.
Motorcycles were allowed to shoot guns.
You're allowed to go skydiving and
bungee jumping.
All those things carry risks,
but it's assumed that any adult that
does them is aware of those risks.
Yeah,
I couldn't agree more.
I mean it's,
it's also who is.
If the society that we live in was just
you and I was,
we were the only two people alive who
are you to tell me what I can do or me
to tell you what you can do.
It's ridiculous.
And so when you have grown adults
telling a grown adult who's informed
what they can and can't do,
then it becomes a question of children.
Well then it becomes an education issue
and it becomes a parental issue.
I mean it's just,
you can't lie to your children about the
effects of certain drugs because then
they're not going to believe you about
the really actual,
the actual dangerous ones.
Right?
And this is of course reflected in the
so called opioid epidemic.
Yes.
Right now,
yes.
There's endless finger pointing.
Everyone wants to find a culprit that's
behind all of it.
And the easiest person to blame,
of course our pharmaceutical companies
because everybody hates pharmaceutical
companies,
so why not blame them?
But you know,
and I'm not pro pharmaceutical by any
stretch of the imagination,
but I'm also not anti pharmaceutical
either.
And when you look at the way,
for example,
the New York Times is covering the
opioid epidemic,
it's always in this tone of like
documents were uncovered,
the show that executives at Purdue
Pharma,
we're aware that morphine was addictive
as early as 1999.
And it's like,
well,
of course,
of course they were aware of.
People have known that morphine is
addictive for hundreds of years.
This is old news and this whole idea
that doctors were convinced by some
letter in the New England Journal of
Medicine that said that Oxycontin isn't
addictive,
is absurd.
These are all morphine derivatives.
Any adult,
especially a medically trained adults,
should know that no matter what little
variation you make on that molecule,
if it's structurally and
pharmacologically and qualitatively
similar to morphine,
of course it's going to be addictive.
And that in of itself isn't even a bad
thing.
It should be okay to give people
addictive drugs as well.
As long as everyone's aware of the
risks,
as long as they understand the protocol
to get off of it.
You,
you know,
there's so many people that get on these
things and then wind up taking them far
longer than they're supposed to because
it's easy to get hooked.
I mean we need to at least have some
sort of responsible
direction of these people need to go to,
to get off of them once they're on them
because people that get back operations,
any anything where they prescribe you
high doses of opiates,
it's a huge problem.
I know many,
many people that have gotten hooked
because of,
and in fact I should tell you that my
good friend Justin wren,
his wife found out about Kratom because
of you,
because of your show,
he had a problem with his shoulder,
got shoulder shoulder surgery,
they put them on Oxycontin's.
He was fucked up on them and he was
having a really hard time getting off
and having the shakes really bad.
And Kratom is the only thing that got
them off it.
Right.
And that's not surprising.
I mean this has been known for a very
long time in Thailand and that was
actually the reason that it was
originally prohibited.
I don't know if you're aware of that,
but because the government taxed opium
and people started using Creton,
then they made Creton Elisa the right
way to say it because people say Kratom,
you're the only one I've heard say
Krypton people in.
It's a Thai word.
People in Thailand call it people in the
US called Kratom.
It's,
I,
it's also,
they have,
you know,
is maybe it's like Crikey,
dom,
something that we're not going to go to
that forever.
Tom is closer.
If you did,
it would be weird,
but I feel as you know,
like American people that say Ecuador,
Argentina,
but it is Creton Creton.
Okay.
So we'll try to call it quits or
something close to that.
It's closer to that thing.
Kratom.
And so the reason why I was made illegal
was because of the fact that it was
pinching some of the profits off of the
opium trade.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
And so this has been known for a long
time that it helps people get off more
addictive opioids.
And how does it do that?
Well,
it's an opioid itself and a lot of
people don't want to admit or
acknowledge that,
but I think we need to get beyond this
idea that drugs are inherently bad or
opioids are inherently bad just because
the ones that we're aware of have a lot
of problems,
you know,
in some sense,
medicinal chemistry and pharmacology and
all of this are still in a very
primitive state and there's so much to
be learned.
So we're mostly giving people these
derivatives of morphine that have been
around for a hundred years and there are
better things.
We're going to continuously discover
less addictive treatments for pain and I
think that the alkaloids in Kratom are a
step in that direction and which is so
tragic that they're trying to now make
it illegal because this is something
that as far as I can tell,
has genuinely helped an enormous number
of people reduce their intake of more
addictive and more dangerous opioids.
Well,
one of the things that I've felt,
I mean,
and again,
my dose was not extremely high,
but when I was on it,
I was very coherent.
I was clear.
It was clear to me that was affected by
something,
but it felt kinda good.
It didn't feel bad.
It felt a little,
a little uneasy,
like a little like,
whoa,
this world feels a little weird right
now,
but it not feel like A.
I was impaired.
Like I know a lot of people who take it
an exercise,
like a,
I have a friend,
he'll take 10 pills and exercise just
just seems kind of fucking crazy.
But he says he has a great workout.
Right.
We're taking that stuff before he works
out.
Yeah.
I mean it seems to lend itself to a lot
of different applications in Thailand.
It's used almost exclusively for that
sort of purpose.
In the south,
it's a drug that Labor is used so they
can collect the latex foam,
rubber trees and just get their job
done.
That's what it's about.
I mean,
that's what opioids are about for a lot
of the world,
both in the United States and in Africa
and in Thailand is,
you know,
people live hard lives and,
and manual labor is painful and
repetitive and difficult and anything
that makes that a little bit more
manageable is very important tool for
humans.
I always felt like people that did
heroin or opiates or something like
that,
we're on a very short road to death
that was my perception when I was a kid.
And then I had a friend who was a
longshoreman.
They worked on the docks bring.
They would bring fish in and fillet the
fish for the market.
And um,
he worked with a guy that everyday at
lunch the guy would go cop,
he would get his heroin,
who would shoot it up in his car and
then he'd go back to work and I was
like,
he'd go back to work and you're like,
Yup.
He worked everyday,
like everyday shot up and everyday he
worked like,
yeah,
it was never late.
Nope,
just did his work.
Wow.
I didn't think you could do that.
I thought you did heroin,
the next thing you know,
you'd just be on the floor in a fetal
position,
in your own urine and you would fall
apart and die.
Right?
Yet there's this idea that people
sometimes refer to as pharmacological
determinism that a certain drug has to
do a certain thing,
so alcohol has to sedate and disinhibit
you.
Heroine has to addict you and make you a
slave to it and kill you.
Cocaine has to be a euphoric thing
that's done at parties.
That's also very addictive.
PCP has to make you strip nude and run
around a fighting,
constantly fighting cops and punching
holes and wooden fences.
Um,
but when you look at this,
you know,
anthropologists have looked at certain
drugs that are used cross culturally
like alcohol.
And what you find is this whole idea of
pharmacological determinism is
fundamentally flawed.
Drugs behave differently in different
cultures depending on the set and
setting of the user.
And so you find all sorts of instances
that are major exceptions to these rules
that we've set up for these various
drugs.
For example,
PCP,
which is arguably one of the most
ubiquitously maligned drugs in the
world,
I mean no one can imagine that PCP is
medicinal,
but even to this day,
pcps and schedule to not schedule one
like cannabis and LSD schedule to it can
still be prescribed actually.
And that's because it had a history of
medicinal
use.
There was even PCP psychotherapy in the
UK,
in the,
in the fifties.
So this is a something that most people
wouldn't believe,
but to those patients that were taking
it,
then there was none of this cultural
association with PCP being a drug that
causes psychosis or makes you strip
nude,
who is simply another tool for a
psychiatrist to use and help people
release repressed memories or traumas
that they were afraid to talk about when
sober.
Well,
we're seeing that now with Mtma,
right?
I mean,
and also ketamine,
ketamine,
you being used as an actual tool for
psychotherapy,
particularly for people with depression.
So having really good results.
My,
um,
my friend,
excuse me,
Neil Brennan,
who is a hilarious comedian.
He's had struggles with depression.
He,
he got great relief from,
uh,
from
taking ketamine.
Right.
And what I think is really interesting
is,
you know,
this is often packaged as a sort of
psychedelic renaissance,
but I think in a larger context,
it's a drug facilitated psychotherapy
renaissance because this was not just
limited to psychedelics.
People did something called narco
analysis where they would give people
sedatives like propofol.
The drug that killed Michael Jackson or
um,
various barbiturates or various other
drugs and the relaxing effect would
allow people to talk more openly to a
therapist.
And it was considered very effective.
Now this idea of a psychiatrist
injecting you with a drug in order to
help you talk about your problems is
it's unheard of.
I don't think anyone does it anymore,
but it used to be very common and I
think a return to that is going to be
really beneficial.
Yeah,
I,
I agree with you.
I think the right drugs with the right
cases and the right people,
and I think we've got to get past these
schedules that when you have things like
marijuana and silicide been and
especially DMT,
which your own body produces is a
schedule one drug and the famous Terence
Mckenna line.
We're all holding.
You know,
when it comes to Dmt,
it's just stupid.
It's just stupid that these things are
scheduled one.
When you're saying there's no medical
benefit whatsoever,
a medical application for cannabis is
fucking crazy.
When something that you want to have
something that really actively promotes
a distrust in law enforcement,
the scheduling of drugs is one of the
best ones because when you look at
something like marijuana and you see
that that's a schedule one drug that,
that that's infuriating to people that
gain huge benefits from cannabis.
I mean people that have going through
chemotherapy,
people that have,
you know,
a interocular pressure from Glaucoma.
I mean you can go down the list over and
over and over again.
The kids that have epilepsy,
there's so many people that have had
great benefit,
particularly from edible cannabis.
People that have seizures,
I mean you could keep going on and on
and on.
It's just,
it's an amazing plant and to have that
demonized because of some ridiculous
propaganda from the 19 thirties that
still somehow or another clung on in
2018.
We think about all the information we
have now with the Internet and the fact
that cannabis is still scheduled.
One,
you have assholes like jeff sessions
still saying things like,
good people don't smoke marijuana like
this is crazy talk.
It's crazy,
but keep in mind it was just about a 100
years ago that alcohol was prohibited in
the United States and it took 13 years
to reverse that and that was alcohol.
There's no drug more integrated into our
culture than alcohol and that took 13
years to reverse.
What was that like back then?
That must have been madness when alcohol
was illegal.
When the cops would come in and
jackbooted thugs would knock over jen
mills and bust open kegs of whiskey and
spill it all out.
Like,
what the fuck was that like?
It was.
It was disastrous.
But I think what's interesting about
that is it was a worthwhile experiment
to give them the benefit of the doubt.
It was worthwhile to see because on some
sense you could say the prohibition has
a certain logic to it.
You could say drugs caused problems.
So if we just make all the drugs
illegal,
then maybe those problems will
disappear,
but it didn't work.
The experiment failed.
And there's nothing wrong with a failed
experiment,
but it's a problem if you keep repeating
it over and over and over again for 100
years looking for a different result.
Right?
And then go to other drugs and go,
well,
this one,
let's try this one.
Let's make this one illegal.
And it's a terrible
pr situation for the police as well.
If I were a police officer,
I'd be the biggest opponent of the war
on drugs and have anyone in the
government.
Because when you think about why does
the average person in New York City love
of firefighter,
they love firefighters,
but they hate cops.
Why is that?
It's because of the drug war.
Because a firefighter isn't going to
hurt you for something that wasn't
really a crime to begin with,
for some kind of victimless crime.
A firefighter is just there to help you
to save you if you're in trouble,
and the same would be true of police
officers if it weren't for the drug war.
Ideally
there's a little more complexity to it.
There's certainly certainly more
complexity when it comes to shootings
and things along those lines,
but I mean the stop and frisks.
I've read something about stop and Frisk
in New York when they had,
when they had that instituted that most
of it was drugs.
Most of it was like catching people with
marijuana.
Yeah.
Which is just fucking insane.
You just stay.
You look like you might be street.
Get over here
and that's the way these laws have
functioned from the very beginning.
I mean,
if you look at drug law in the UK,
it tends to be very black and white.
Something is legal or illegal.
If it's legal,
it can be sold in stores because it's
legal.
If it's illegal,
it can't be sold anywhere in the US.
They've instead created this nebulous
far reaching gray area where there's all
sorts of things that are maybe illegal,
kind of illegal,
do it,
but don't get caught and uh,
and it's created and ability for the
government to selectively prosecuted
people whenever they want,
if they want.
Mm.
Yeah.
Well that seems to be lessening.
I mean,
when you have someone like Jeff sessions
in office,
it's very disturbing,
but then trump says things like he's
very strong on states rights to past
marijuana laws and things along those
lines.
You're very incredulous.
No,
no.
I mean,
I,
I suppose I am a bit incredulous when it
comes to trump doing anything good.
But,
uh,
I think if you told him that people love
him more,
if he did things good,
he would do things good.
That's probably true.
I think of someone that he trusted said,
yeah,
I think that's as I think we've got to
get somebody in deep.
We've got to get them all in there.
Got To get somebody who's good at back
rubs get,
gets back on the podcast and I think
that'll help.
I doubt it will help.
I mean,
it just,
I don't know,
what is the thing that'll help.
There's also the separation between the
drug users and the policymakers.
Yes,
and one thing that I am certain will
help,
and it's sort of tragic that this is the
case,
but it's capitalism.
It's the corporatization of these drugs
because with cannabis,
um,
you know,
when it was hippies and the
counterculture having marches down the
streets of New York holding up for 20
signs,
it doesn't,
I suppose have all that much clout in
the eyes of lawmakers,
but when you have some guy from Yale
business school who's never smoked weed,
who says,
you know,
this is a serious business opportunity,
we're going to make it big and gets
investors,
invest millions and millions of dollars
into it.
Hires lobbyists,
plays the game like a capitalist.
Then the laws do change and I wish that
weren't the case,
but it is.
And it's tragic for the people that did
fight and did go to prison and did
sacrifice that.
Then these,
these business school guys come along
and reap all the benefits,
but that's the way it works.
Yeah.
That is the way it is
and that's okay.
I mean it's just a weird path.
It's a weird path,
but as long as we can get to
legalization,
I'm 100 percent for that path.
I just think that might be the only way
in this weird country,
this country is so enamored with money.
I mean we're,
we're so enamored with money and profits
and even for dying people,
even old people like Warren Buffet
invested shit.
Tons of money in warehouses to sell to,
to grow cannabis in Colorado when the
laws were passed.
I mean that guy has 150,000
years old.
He's worth billions of dollars and he's
like,
who gives a shit?
I'm making more money now and more and
more and more.
I mean even when they're really old,
they're massively motivated by profit.
Yes,
and I think the same will be true for
psychedelics and we'll probably be true
for all of these things because you need
to have lobbyists need to have this sort
of typical white collar support to push
things forward.
I agree.
I just,
I don't see any other way around it
right now.
I mean,
the real hope is that cannabis,
not that it will get rid of capitalism,
but that we'll figure it out.
It's hard to wear those things with
glasses on,
right?
Yes.
They are always talking about it.
The glasses digging your head that
cannabis will.
W did not just cannabis,
but Campbell's will open the door to all
these different substances that will
allow people to have to gain a greater
perspective.
This is the ultimate goal,
in my opinion,
is to give people the opportunity to
step outside of the momentum of their
lives and look at things with fresh eyes
and make clear decisions.
This is one of the best things that I
think that drugs provide is that these
psychedelic drugs in particular provide
an escape from the momentum of this life
that you've created or that you found
yourself a part of.
It's very difficult for people to stop
behavior patterns to stop and just look
at themselves objectively and sort of
rethink,
regroup and reassess and this is one of
the best things about cannabis and about
suicide,
but in a lot of these other psychedelic
drugs is that it gives you this newfound
perspective that allows you to
reconsider things.
Yes,
absolutely.
And I think with Ketamine in the
treatment of depression,
it's a similar idea because depressed
people become used to these very
ingrained patterns of thinking and
anything that can break you out of that,
that can shake it up for a minute and
maybe give you a different perspective I
think is inherently therapeutic.
Yeah,
I think so as well.
And I think
I'm hoping that what I see,
and this is what I believe I see,
is that we're changing our perceptions
of it.
I had a conversation with a friend of
mine the other day about marijuana
where,
uh,
we were talking about,
um,
how you used to hide whether or not you
did it from certain people and now that
group of people that you have to hide it
from a smaller and smaller and that it
seems like everyone casually smokes
marijuana now in,
in our circles,
there's so many people that do.
There's a few that don't sober people in
whatever,
but it's way more common.
Whereas 10,
15 years ago,
this was something you hid if you had a
good job,
if you had a family.
This is not something you want people to
know about
in.
What I think is really interesting is
that in and of itself changes the nature
of the cannabis experience.
So I think if somebody uses cannabis in
a culture that supports it,
that approves of it,
their experience will be better by
virtue of that fact.
So there's a certain shame that a lot of
people feel when using any drug I,
for whatever crazy reason,
feel it a little bit with cannabis.
It's a little just a hair of I should
be,
you know,
I should be studying,
should be reading.
They should be you more focused.
This is a little hedonistic.
It's little comfort oriented.
I should be working harder,
but that's I think just the vestiges of
this propaganda that I've been fed or
something like that.
Or maybe it's true,
but I understand from one perspective
why the cannabis culture,
drums,
the benefits of cannabis so hard.
You know that it cures all disease,
that it's good for you,
that it cures cancer,
all this stuff.
Because if you have that in your mind,
at the very least,
it's going to reduce that sort of
internal shame that you might feel it
makes the entire experience healthier
and more beneficial because we do
construct these limitations.
We construct these experiences to some
extent.
So if you decide that cannabis is a
dissociative drug that's hedonistic and
comfort oriented and will take you away
from your responsibilities and that's
what it will become,
but if you decide like Terence Mckenna
did,
that it's an intellectual catalyst that
it will facilitate your ability to read
and learn and think and write,
then it will become that as well.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird one,
right?
Because people that are people that take
it,
that are prone to paranoia or that are
dealing with some difficult issues in
their life right now that they're
perhaps trying to avoid,
it becomes an uncomfortable experience.
Whereas people that are happy and having
a good time and in a good place,
the marijuana will sort of enhance that.
He was loving,
warm feeling of,
of comfort and have like sort of
acceptance of your existence and it's
going to be okay.
Right?
But I think even the paranoia is like a
sort of sort of,
um,
meme you could say a sort of vestige of
this propaganda that makes people afraid
in the same vein as the bad trip.
I think the concept of a bad trip is a
very damaging concept because,
and I know from personal experience,
I never really used psychedelics in high
school with the exception of Salvia,
um,
because I was terrified of a bad trip.
Talk to friends who'd described bad
trips and they say,
oh,
it's bad.
It's bad trip.
It's really bad.
It's scary.
And I would think,
oh,
that's terrible.
I could,
I would never want a bad trip.
I'm never going to touch these things
because a bad trip would be too much for
me to tolerate.
And then I started using psychedelics
and I realized there's no such thing as
a bad trip anymore than there's a bad
meal or a bad relationship or a bad day.
I mean,
having an occasional bad thing in life
doesn't stop you from doing things like
eating or having relationships or living
typically.
So what do you mean by this?
Are you saying there's no such thing as
a bad trip saying there's no such thing
as a bad meal?
I'm saying that there is such thing as a
bad meal but.
But it wouldn't prevent you from
tripping.
And I think that even the bad or
wouldn't prevent you from eating rather
sorry about that,
but uh,
but I think even these bad trips,
although they can be difficult,
are beneficial and our learning
experience in the same way that a bad
meal could be.
You learned not to go to that restaurant
or maybe you learned something about
what makes you sick or what to be
careful of in the future.
You,
if you are approaching life from a non
fearful perspective where your intention
is to learn,
then you can extract benefit from almost
any experience and these difficult
psychedelic experiences.
I genuinely believe,
and this is what is maybe the hardest
thing to communicate about psychedelics,
is that it's the difficult ones that are
often the best.
Those are the ones that really teach you
something.
And when you're trying to talk about
psychedelics with people who've never
used them,
it's not a great selling point to say,
oh,
you know,
the best thing that can happen is you're
going to think you're going to die.
But that is arguably the best thing that
can happen.
To think that you're going to die
because that's a confrontation with the
overarching fear,
the fear of that generates all other
fears and if you conquer that fear,
then
your life will almost certainly
improved.
Well,
what is one thing that's sort of
genuine,
genuinely universally accepted as a
beneficial experience is a near death
experience,
sort of universally accepted as a
transformative moment in people's lives.
Like I had this near death experience
and I realized,
wow,
I gotta get my shit together.
After that heart attack,
I realized that life is a gift and I
changed the way I think about things and
I started calling people that I loved
and telling them that I loved them.
This is the same.
You can get a near death experience from
cannabis.
You just don't ever tie,
but you really do.
I mean,
it's the death of so many perceptions
and so many things about your life,
especially from edible cannabis,
which I think is probably one of the
least understood and most potent things
that people are consuming on a daily
basis.
I,
I can't tell you how many times I've
given someone edible marijuana in their
fucking convinced that it's been laced
with something awful and that they're
going to die,
but then afterwards they come out of it
and they're like,
oh,
so I got some work to do.
The only way I would disagree with you
is people that are prone to psychotic
breaks because that there,
there is an absolute genuine connection
between people who have a slippery hold
on reality and some experiences with
psychedelics that lead them down a bad
road.
That's true.
It can.
It's a stressor and like all stressors,
it can precipitate a psychotic break.
A,
they've done pretty large scale
epidemiological analyses of psychedelic
drug users versus the non psychedelic
drug using population and the incidence
of mental illness isn't any higher.
So I don't think you can argue that
psychedelics cause mental illness,
but you can add it in some measures.
It seems to actually reduce it in terms
of things like alcoholism,
substance abuse disorders.
But,
um,
but it can be a stressor that would
precipitate such an episode in a
susceptible individual.
And I had a very traumatic and formative
experience myself for my best friend had
a psychotic break while I was with him
tripping.
So I've seen this firsthand.
I know exactly what it looks like.
Yeah.
I've had friends.
I have real
bad experiences too where they're
screaming and yelling and then
disassociative and then afterwards
become very strange and have a really
hard time with reality for a bit.
Yeah.
I've never seen someone have a complete
psychotic break promise that he never
recovered.
He never,
he never recovered.
He was my best friend at the time and he
never recovered.
So he was fine before the psychedelic.
Yes.
Jesus Christ light again.
You know,
it's.
And that happened early.
So now he's still fucked.
Yes.
But again,
you know,
I,
I typically don't tell that story in
public because it's could be
misinterpreted as a scare story.
You know,
I don't.
It's impossible to prove the
counterfactual.
Would it have happened without
psychedelics?
Almost certainly.
I can't say.
All I know is that he took a very high
dose of a Silicon Ester and um,
had this episode,
he was hospitalized and he was not the
same afterwards.
So I'm aware that this is something that
happens,
but it also typically happens in the
early twenties,
late teens,
the same time that people typically have
psychotic breaks and develop
schizophrenia.
Yeah.
The incident.
This is of schizophrenia in people who
use cannabis are a cannabis in
particular,
but I don't know about other
psychedelics,
but I would imagine they're very
similar.
They're exactly the same as the
incidences of schizophrenia and non
using populations.
It's like one percent,
one percent across the board seemed to
have issues with schizophrenia.
And the real question is how many of
those people could mean isn't avoidable
if your friend had never done that and
instead had become a marathon runner or
something and know,
found some other outlets for his energy,
would he have never gone down that road?
We don't know.
It's impossible.
So I think it's very important to talk
about that though.
And with further research,
perhaps we could isolate jeans they have
for cte now they have,
they can do an analysis of your genes
and then determine whether or not
something like football and be a
dangerous path for you because you have
a higher probability of developing cte.
It would be wonderful if they figured
out a way to do that with psilocybin or
with cannabis or with anything else and
be able to recognize the potential links
to psychotic breaks and to,
you know,
a host of different mental disorders
that could possibly be triggered by high
doses.
Yes.
I mean this is one of so many things
that needs to be done and that's,
you know,
everyone's very excited about all of
this clinical research that's happening
right now.
I'm excited about it as well.
But on one level it is very politically
oriented research,
you know,
the things that they're looking at have
actually typically been done before.
Not all of it,
but the aim is to firmly establish these
things that have been known for a long
time.
Silicide been occasions,
mystical type experience or Mtma is
useful for treating ptsd or psilocybin
has an anti addictive effect.
These are things that people have known
for a little while,
but now it's about proving it,
but I'm really looking forward to
getting deeper into these serious
questions about,
you know exactly how these drugs
interact with various subtypes of
serotonin receptors because I think that
they're going to be very important tools
for understanding consciousness as a
whole.
Yeah.
It would also be interesting knowing how
they react to different diets.
You know,
when people are,
you know,
when you're eating certain types of
foods that are bad for your body,
I would really be curious to see what
kind of effect that has.
I mean when,
when you have real large scale research
that goes over really important
variables in terms of human health and
then you add in these different
substances,
whether it's silicide or cannabis or
whatever it is.
It's,
it's gonna be interesting to see how the
body reacts to these various
preturbances,
these various changes of your state.
Yeah,
and that's,
you know,
traditionally in a lot of these
indigenous groups,
the Diet plays a big role in the way
that the drug is administered and I
think we're slowly rediscovering a lot
of things that have been known for tens,
maybe hundreds,
maybe thousands of years,
and some of these indigenous groups.
Have you had a chance to see any of my
new show?
No,
no,
I haven't.
Oh,
I think you'd like it.
I'm sure I'd liked it.
I liked her old show.
This is,
I think it's a lot better than the old
show.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
but I,
you know,
I had the opportunity to look at the way
Salvia is used in the mountains of
Wahaca and you know,
native American peyote use and all these
different things and yeah,
there's so much to be learned from all
of these traditions that are not
reflected in the current clinical
climate because they can't be.
But I think that that's going to be a
part of it is slowly integrating these
other alkaloids that are present in the
plants to see what role they play in the
same way that,
you know,
the initial medicalization of cannabis
was Marinol,
which is just phc and sesame oil,
but now there's increased understanding
of the way these accessory cannabinoids
modulate the thc experience or whether
thc is even the primary therapeutic
agent for certain disorders.
And I imagine the same thing will be
true for Peo Odi and for the Iboga
alkaloids and probably even for some of
the chemicals found in mushrooms.
So when you're doing this show,
have you had any problems?
Have you had any,
uh,
push back against what you're doing or
any,
any issues with it?
Being on vice?
I've had an enormous amount of freedom,
you know,
ultimately I have very little to
complain about when it comes to
censorship.
There was,
um,
it,
the way the show got started,
the actual TV show is sort of an
interesting story where they were
starting up vice land and a producer
who's now gone a gave me this deck of
drug stories they were going to do and
there are all kinds of terrible scare
stories like the new drug Bromo Dragon
flying.
It's killing teens and new drug Bromo
driving.
Yeah.
What does that,
it's a really fascinating compound
developed by this chemist David Nichols,
who,
um,
found that,
that these confirmation,
highly constrained Benzo fear in a
amphetamine derivatives are like very
high potency dob derivatives.
Anyway,
it's just a,
it's a super potent psychedelic
amphetamine that has a cool tryciclics
structure.
Huh?
Then it looks like a dragon fly.
The molecule looks like a dragon fly
kind of.
And it's got a very high,
isn't it?
It's super,
super potent and very,
very long lasting.
So it lent itself to scare stories.
Um,
you know,
people,
it is a potent vasoconstrictor so people
will take very high doses of it and
occasionally they would have to amputate
a finger or something like that.
But again,
you know,
this isn't because the drug is bad,
it's because people used it
irresponsibly and this is something that
people have so much difficulty
understanding.
We're so eager to blame drugs for all of
our problems.
Drugs have never heard anyone.
They're just inanimate constellations of
carbon and hydrogen,
nitrogen and oxygen.
They don't jump out of their bags and
vials and attack your serotonin
receptors for dopamine transport or
anything like that.
So this is just a weird pattern that
we've done repeatedly over time.
And I don't know if you read the new
Michael Paulin book.
I know he was on the podcast I'm in
right now.
Yeah,
it's great.
it is great.
But,
um,
one thing that I thought was interesting
about it is that he put a lot of the
emphasis on the prohibition of
psychedelics on leary and leary almost
certainly played a role,
but I think it's slightly ironic that
he's a journalist and didn't really go
that deep into the role that journalists
played in all of this,
which was humongous.
You know,
journalists are sculptors of public
opinion and it became the standard way
of reporting on any of these things to
say that they're bad,
to sensationalize it and to not have any
consideration for what that would do
because anytime a journalist writes him
scare story,
they can really mess with drug policy in
a serious way.
It might seem like nothing like,
oh,
there's a bunch of people in Brooklyn
and they overdosed on some obscure
synthetic cannabinoid amb food minuka
who cares about amb food Venica no big
deal.
Say that it turns people into zombies
and if it gets thrown into schedule one,
who cares?
Not a big deal.
Well,
that's a very short sighted way of
thinking about all of this because
that's exactly what happened with
psychedelics and then we're not learning
from the mistakes of the past that just
because something it's fun to
sensationalize and talk about how
dangerous it is at this moment doesn't
mean that 10 years from now we're going
to recognize it as serious therapeutic
potential and we made a big mistake
outlawing it and I think a lot of that
also comes from this sort of us versus
them mentality that people have where
it's cannabis is good.
Synthetic cannabinoids are bad.
Well synthetic cannabinoids don't have
to be bad for cannabis to be good.
Cannabis can be good without something
else being bad.
To counterbalance that you don't need to
hate something to justify your love of
cannabis and this whole hatred of
synthetic cannabinoids I think is
totally misdirected because these are
products of prohibition that most people
wouldn't even want to use in the first
place and when they do use them,
they don't know what they're taking.
They don't know what dose they're
consuming and so of course they're
having bad experiences.
That would happen with almost any drug,
caffeine included if people just
consumed enormous unmeasured doses
without having any idea what they were
getting into and so they're thrown into
schedule one or what happens if 30 years
from now,
once the therapeutic potential of
cannabinoids as being really seriously
explored,
we find out that that Ambi Food Venica
that everyone was saying turned homeless
people into zombies in Brooklyn in 2017
turns out to activate a certain subtype
of the CB one receptor that's especially
useful for Parkinson's disease or
something like that.
Then we're going to regret having done
that.
So I think people have to be very
careful.
Anytime you say anything negative about
a drug,
you have to be very,
very careful because the implications
can be enormous.
I think that the best stance and all of
this is to not speak ill of drug
drug.
The drugs are true drug enthusiastic,
but it's not a problem.
Also with just what journalism is.
It's like asking a comedian to talk
about something but not make fun of it.
That's what their job in a certain sense
is to get people excited about things.
And I don't know whether you'd say the
lazy way out or the common approach is
to say something that scares people.
I mean that's.
That's what clickbait is mostly about
either outrage or fear.
That's true,
but there's a lot of richness in truth.
I agree,
but it's hard to sell.
It's hard to settle that rich and hard
to sell.
I think the people are
lazy,
you know,
is this idea that a lot of people have
that,
you know,
journalism is organized by some
malevolent Rupert Murdoch type puppeteer
who's telling everyone to.
You go off and you say that cannabis
causes car accidents.
When you go off and you say this evil
thing about this and say that again.
Alcohol is good.
Did you see when a Alex Jones was on my
podcast and got high with me when I'm
drunk and I.
and when it came up in his trial for his
divorce,
he said that George Soros puts a.
He tests marijuana every year to see how
much George Soros is influencing the
levels of thc was his excuse that people
love these ideas.
They love the ideas of the,
the malevolent
puppeteer.
Because it denies individual agency,
but the reality,
and I say this as a journalist who's
worked at many different publications,
not just vice is,
and this is a difficult reality to
swallow,
is that people are free to say whatever
they want.
Most of the time journalists choose to
report on things this way.
It's true,
but it's also true that they like.
I've been a part of stories that I've
talked to the author of it and they
said,
well,
this was manipulated by the editor.
The editor manipulated the title,
the chain.
It's a great excuse the perspective,
but it's true.
Like the rolling stone did an article
about me and they called me as
psychedelic warrior and I said to the
guy who wrote down,
what the fuck is that?
I was laughing and he goes,
dude,
I did not write that.
Yeah.
The editor gets a hold of it,
tries to make it more salacious.
It becomes something that's
more.
It's more likely for people to buy or
click.
Right.
Especially with headlines that that is
true and the real problem is that the
sort of outrage culture and comment
culture that has emerged provides no
incentive for truth because suppose
someone were to write an article about
this conversation we're having right now
and it could say Hamilton Morris says
Creton should be illegal,
or something like that.
Then that will get so much more
engagement because then you'll have all
these people saying,
fuck Hamilton.
He,
he's a,
he's a trader.
How dare he say that?
It should be illegal that it didn't
watch it and then you'll have other
people arguing with those people saying,
well,
listen to the interview.
Hey,
he actually never said anything about
that and listened carefully to what you
saying and then you create this whole
engagement,
a bigger engagement for doing the wrong
thing.
Then you'd get for doing the right
True,
but.
But
the initial statement is much stickier.
The initial statement of Hamilton Morris
is a bad guy because he thinks kratom
should be illegal or Katam should be
illegal.
That is what more people are going to
pay attention to.
Far less people read the retraction than
read the initial worries.
This is one of the more insidious things
about printing things that are patently
untrue,
purposely that people do do things that
are untrue with the caveat that they
could just print a retraction that maybe
30 percent of the people that read the
original article,
we're going to read that.
The initial imprint is what's going to
stick with people.
Even if you.
Someone calls you a rapist,
okay,
and then it turns out that the person
who called you a rapist was lying.
The people heard you were a rapist
first.
They still have that in their head.
Oh,
he's a rapist rapist,
right?
It's just,
it's very difficult to get slippery
ideas out of people's heads.
So if somebody writes some articles
saying that you're against the
legalization of certain drugs and they
start looking at you as being
compromised,
it's the influence that people have
today can't be understated because the
reach is so powerful.
The reach of any article,
any video,
any.
It's so significantly greater than any
other sort of distribution of
information in the history of human
beings.
They have the
potential for it impacting large groups
of people is so huge now.
Yes,
and this is the result of that is also
that the viewers have a lot of power and
I think that in some sense they don't
quite recognize the nature of that
power.
It's like voting with your dollar.
If you spend all of your time commenting
hatefully on things you don't like,
you are actively encouraging the
production of more of that thing that
you don't like.
If you like something,
you need to engage with what you approve
of more because every time you engage
with something you dislike,
advertisements are sold and it has been
incentivized to do that bad thing and
that's a really sticky thing when we
have this culture where everyone loves
to out show their outrage and virtue
signal and show that they're on the
right side and all this stuff constantly
to say,
hey,
step back.
You're just feeding the problem.
Yeah.
I think there's also a problem with a
lot of what people are doing during the
day is something they don't want to do.
A lot of what people are doing is some
job that they don't enjoy and during
that job they have freedom to go online
and in this state of feeling like shit
about what they're doing,
they enjoy complaining about stuff and
so the they'll read things and type
things and get engaged in things and
there's some sort of a sport getting
pissed off about stuff.
Instead of just spending your time doing
things you actually enjoy.
It seems so simple.
It sounds like a simple solution,
but if you could figure out a way to
actively ignore things that are going to
piss you off and seek out things that
are going to excite you and intrigue
you,
you're going to be a healthier,
happier person and it doesn't.
That is that ultimately what everybody
wants.
I want to be happier.
Don't you want to be happier?
Of course,
but why do we seek out shit that pisses
us off?
Because it becomes a sort of addiction.
It's drug like in and of itself.
I mean,
I see it.
These arguments,
these people are frittering away,
finite time on earth,
engage in these endless common battles
that no one reads and uh,
and it's a very dark reality,
but it is also something that's driving
the current culture of journalism that
we're.
Truth doesn't matter as much.
All that matters is engagement,
right?
It's just clicks.
It's just clicks and money.
It's interesting that you were saying
something about drugs being inanimate
objects and drugs don't actually kill
people.
It's so funny how drug enthusiast
parallel gun enthusiasts with their
arguments.
It's really the same freedom argument
and it's,
it's really,
I'm in an interesting perspective
because I live in New York.
I'm like a whatever,
just a nerdy guy that doesn't let me
guess.
You live in Williamsburg.
I do a big surprise.
So that's where the office,
I live close to the office that I work
at,
but uh,
but you know,
I have no interest in guns.
I'm not,
so it's really easy for me to say,
well look,
there was this shooting and
all these people died and uh,
and this other guy got shot and these
things are really causing a lot of
problems.
Let's get rid of them because it doesn't
impact me and that's where you have to
be the most careful because the worst
thing you can possibly do is make
judgments about how other people should
conduct their lives based on your own
preferences which people do all the
time.
So you hear someone say,
well,
I don't like cannabis.
I don't like him.
I don't smoke it.
Why should it be legal?
Because people go to prison for it
because it ruins people's lives who
aren't your own.
And you have to think about people that
aren't you.
And so it's very difficult when it comes
to gun control issues because this,
I'm faced with that exact same issue
where it would be so easy for me to say,
get rid of them all.
It doesn't impact me.
I don't like guns,
but I don't want to fall into that same
trap.
Yeah,
it is a trap
and it's,
it also sort of highlights how slippery
life is in general that these absolutes
that we look for,
these ones and Zeros,
they don't necessarily exist in a lot of
subjects.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of people that have done
bad things that have also done great
things and that gets weird to,
you know,
just human beings in general.
We're,
we're not,
we're,
we're complex preachers,
you know,
and to just categorize something as
negative or positive,
it's,
there's a lot of positive things that
you could find with drugs.
There's a lot of negative things you
could find the drugs too,
and they,
mere human behavior does a lot of
positive and negatives and humans
behavior.
Yes.
And back to this,
this journalistic issue in the coverage
of drugs,
I mean,
one thing that worries me about the way
cannabis and Creton and psychedelics are
presented is that it's always couched in
their safe.
They're therapeutic,
they're spiritual,
they're historical,
but that isn't the point.
Even if all those things are true and
there's some debate,
eventually someone will find a chink in
that armor.
Someone will die.
Maybe they're not,
haven't been used as long as you thought
they were used.
Maybe they don't always work
therapeutically,
so then what do you go back to?
Prohibition?
No,
that's why I think you need to emphasize
cognitive liberty.
You need to emphasize people to write,
to explore these alternate states of
consciousness regardless of whether or
not they're therapeutic or safe or
traditional or spiritual.
The point isn't that it's safe or any of
these other things.
The point is that if you want to live in
a free society,
you have to be allowed to take a certain
amount of risk.
Yeah,
that's.
That's a big point.
That's a very big point and I think it
really fits well with your description
of the things that people are allowed to
do that are legal,
that are very dangerous,
like race,
car driving,
bungee jumping,
all these things that we just allow them
to do.
We don't think twice about it using a
parachute.
All that crazy shit.
We just openly and nobody's saying,
hey,
we should ban skydiving.
There was no one saying that.
The fucking.
A lot of people die.
Skydiving,
man.
I mean,
it's fucking dangerous.
We don't seem to care.
We seem to care about drugs because we
think that somehow or another,
either our children or someone we know
is going to be insidiously infected with
these things they're going to get into
their lives and,
and fuck them up.
You know?
And I think the real problem with that
is education.
That's the real problem with that.
I was extremely fortunate in a weird way
to see someone with a cocaine addiction
when I was in high school as a good
friend's cousin who got really fucked up
on cocaine when he was a couple of years
older than me and I watched his life
fall apart and I remember thinking when
I was little like wow,
I don't want to touch that shit.
Like cocaine's fucking terrible.
And then from then on I've never done
cocaine,
but it's because of that education
because of.
And I think real education is something
Pitsa fucking tough thing because you
don't really just get it from knowing
information.
You have to see things,
you have to talk to people,
you have to experience things in your
own.
Like if someone talks about
psychedelics,
someone teaches about psychedelics,
but they have no experience in actual
psychedelic states personally.
It's a very hollow conversation.
It's like a certain amount of education
has to be from real life experience.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
And the other thing is just again,
this idea of pharmacological
determinism,
like I had a friend that was very,
very,
very seriously addicted to cocaine and
had the resources to do immense
quantities every single day.
And he'd always say,
well,
you know,
if I try heroin,
I know it's all over for me.
I know that will be the last straw,
so I'm never touching that stuff and he
didn't.
But my own perspective,
you know,
I've essentially tried everything and if
you really just think about these things
you can actually learn.
For example,
I've tried heroin once,
I didn't think.
Was that interesting?
Did you do it injecting?
No,
you snort it.
I snorted it.
Yeah.
What was it like?
It was boring,
I think.
Boring.
Yeah.
I don't think opiates are very
interesting drugs psychologically.
You know,
if I were to be totally honest,
I think the cannabis is more euphoric
and has so few side effects.
You know,
opioids cause horrible constipation.
They cause all kinds of weird sweating
problems.
I don't think they're especially
pleasant drugs,
but they're romanticized so much in our
culture that people think that's it.
Heroin,
the ultimate high.
Well maybe it isn't.
Maybe it's not even that great at all.
Maybe it's garbage and it doesn't even
matter.
That's the same way I feel about snorted
cocaine.
I don't even think it's a good drug.
It's not an issue of it's so addictive.
You've got to stay away from it because
it's so damn good.
It's not good.
It's not even an enjoyable high.
It has a short duration.
It you then feel bad almost immediately
afterwards.
It's a flawed substance.
Same is true of alcohol,
I think as well.
Alcohol is a crazily flawed molecule.
It's terrible.
No other drug that I can think of causes
a hangover of that type where there's a
toxic metabolite that poisons you.
The following day,
Dr Carl Hart
was trying to explain to me what that is
and essentially he was saying that when
you are getting a hangover,
it's your body reacting to the addictive
properties of alcohol,
that you're getting addicted to alcohol
almost almost immediately that your body
is compensating for that and then these,
this,
this hangover is not just you being
dehydrated,
it's also your body withdrawing from
alcohol.
I would.
I am not familiar with any evidence for
that.
Dr Garcia actually tried to enter in the
forum when I first moved to love that
guy.
Yeah,
he.
I have a lot of respect for them,
but I mean there's a.
I'd have to look at is source for that.
You'd have to also look at the way I
described it because I probably
butchered it.
Okay,
but there's an alternate explanation
that's even simpler,
which is simply that alcohol is
metabolized into chemical assets held to
high.
That's toxic so and with alcohol,
it's a very,
very weak drug.
By weight,
you're consuming insane amounts in terms
of the number of molecules you're
consuming insane quantities of the drug.
So all of this acid aldehyde accumulates
in your body and it has a directly toxic
effect.
Is there a way to counteract that?
Mitigate the effects?
Yes,
there are proposed ways to do it.
I haven't experimented with any of them
myself because they don't really like
alcohol that much to begin with is in a
glutathione that's a,
that's something that allows your body
to process it more easily.
It would have to be something that
prevents this specific conversion.
I don't know off the top of my head.
What about Krokodil?
You ever fuck with that stuff?
Well,
this is another perfect example.
So you take a drug like Krokodil and
it's,
it sounds horrible.
The Internet's drug the other fear drug,
yet people are.
But behind every scare story,
there's nothing.
Explain what that is.
So there's a scare story that,
I believe it was in Moscow somewhere in
Russia in,
and this was hitting the news around
2004.
No,
no,
much later,
2010,
something like that.
I don't know.
And um,
and the idea was that this is the worst
stuff.
It's ultra addictive.
You inject it and then you lose a limb
and you have profound necrosis all
around the injection site,
and this is the worst drug,
most addictive drug of all time.
Well,
the drug itself is called desert
morphine and it's been used medicinally.
There's nothing especially addictive or
dangerous at all that desert morphine.
The problem is that people were
injecting completely impure reaction
mixtures that had all of the components
from the synthesis that hadn't been
removed,
including phosphorus,
which is immensely toxic,
so you have people basically reporting
on ivy phosphorus toxicity as if it were
a result of this drug when it's a
completely separate issue,
and this is what you see when you look
at all of these things.
It's never the drug,
any drug scare story.
It's never the drug.
You always have to look for the root
cause because it's never the drug.
There's never been a drug in history and
that is why if you look at the dea list
of controlled substances,
it's not dangerous drugs that are
controlled.
It's enjoyable drugs.
Something like tetrodotoxin the chemical
and puffer fish.
That's not a controlled substance.
There's some regulations in terms of how
much you can purchase,
but it's not a controlled substance.
Sega toxin,
the most potent known neurotoxin.
It's not a controlled substance.
Lead isn't a controlled substance.
Mercury isn't a controlled substance.
Mercury chloride isn't a controlled
substance.
All of the deadly poisons.
Cyanide isn't a controlled substance.
It's not about what's safe and what's
dangerous.
It's about what people like to use.
What's enjoyable,
what is the root of that.
I think it's,
you know,
a puritanical idea that,
that any sort of euphoria is bad.
I mean,
euphoria is listed as a side effect in
some medications.
We assume that it's a bad thing to deal
with diarrhea.
It's like euphoria.
Diarrhea.
Yeah.
That is a strange thing.
Like that's gonna.
It's gonna,
cut back productivity,
make you a lazy Ne'er do well and just
become a,
a burden on society.
That's common,
common way of describing people use
drugs.
Sure.
And this fundamental idea that sobriety
is good.
Yes.
You know,
you look on Instagram,
people post a selfie and say six months
sober.
Guys,
thank you so much and tons of
congratulations because it's a virtue
because you accomplished something.
You're not using drugs.
Yeah.
Whereas in other cultures that would not
be the case.
People would just say,
Oh,
you've decided not to work with a a
certain medicine.
That's an interesting choice.
Not An accomplishment.
I was saying,
was it Kyle Kingsbury there was saying
that how much he hates the term plant
medicine or was it Dennis?
That was kyle.
You don't like the term plant medicine,
do I don't?
Well,
Dubai is a.
it's a weird sort of pretentious.
Yes.
I know.
Well,
people call Iowasca the medicine or
things like that.
Yeah.
Or towed medicine.
I mean,
I wouldn't.
You don't hate it.
I a lot of these,
like more flowery terms.
Again,
theologian,
I just don't use them myself,
but I don't hate it.
Would your,
you know,
I think people like you are very
important and I'm a big fan,
but I think one of the reasons why
you're important as you are a cognitive
center of real drugs like you,
you understand what they actually do.
You could explain them to the layman or
you could debate them with someone who
was a doctor perhaps that wanted to,
you know,
to talk about the dangers of them and
you understand all the various aspects
of it and I think there's a tremendous
amount of ignorance when it comes to
drugs,
drug consumption.
What is a drug?
I mean,
how many times have you seen a person
with a beer in their hand smoking a
cigarette saying they don't do drugs.
It is so fucking stupid,
but it's.
It's so common.
There is this very,
very,
very common aspect of being a person
which is these desire to change your
mental state and we've done it
throughout history with various
substances,
but there's so much stigma attached to
it and one of the things I've been doing
lately on stage,
I'll ask people,
how many people get piss tested at work?
It's fucking stunning.
It's stunning.
It's like more than 10 percent of the
audience will raise their hand.
Like one out of 10 people gets through
their body tested to make sure that
while they're not working,
they're.
They're not putting anything in their
body.
That's prohibited,
which is such a horrible invasion of
privacy that became so popular that in
the eighties during one presidential
election,
all the candidates voluntarily had their
urine tested to prove that they were
sober.
I mean,
this is like truly considered a virtue
and it's immensely invasive.
I say this as someone who's analyzed my
own urine in a laboratory before and
it's like a strange portal into your own
life that you're showing to a stranger.
Everything that you've consumed is then
a parent there.
Yeah,
and it's incredibly.
It's a huge invasion of privacy that
we've just decided is acceptable and you
have to be very careful about these
things.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
It's and of course the synthetic
cannabinoid epidemic,
if you want to call it that,
I actually don't want to call it that
because I hate even the idea of a drug
epidemic,
but the popularity of synthetic
cannabinoids is largely driven by the
fact that they didn't show up on these
urine tests,
so initially it was in the military than
it was people who are on parole or
probation.
People who were living hard lives
wanting to get high,
couldn't get high.
This was a way that they could do it,
and so they've incentivized people that
just wanted to smoke weed using
completely untested synthetic
cannabinoids instead,
as a direct result of these urine tests.
Well,
it's also just a complete
misunderstanding that comes to the
actual effects and how long they last
you.
Now you're not even testing a person's
conscious state.
You're testing whether or not a person
has altered their state of consciousness
outside of their working time.
You know,
it's not like you show up and they could
scan your hand and realize that you're
high on marijuana right now.
That's not what they're doing.
What they're doing is they're testing
you for something that could linger in
your body for weeks after the
psychoactive effects of long since gone,
Oh yeah.
Or even be the result of passive
exposure.
There was a great scientific article
that came out a couple of years ago
where they found that just passive
exposure to cannabis smoke contaminates
your hair with thc so that all these
people who had hair tests,
who actually had not smoked cannabis,
but it sounds like an excuse,
I was just in the room,
someone else is doing it,
just being in contact with someone who'd
smoked cannabis could then deposit thc
in your hair and cause you to test
positive so these tests aren't even
necessarily reliable.
This is the same problem.
There was a kind of trend a little while
ago,
I don't know if you saw about this,
where people would get their urine for
different to quantify the levels of
neurotransmitter metabolites in the
urine and this was supposed to be like a
fingerprint of your mood,
so they'd quantify the level of
Serotonin,
dopamine,
Gaba,
whatever,
and then they'd say,
oh,
you're a little low on Saratonin.
You're pretty depressed.
Actually.
You need to supplement with some five
htp or something like that.
It's a very reductive way of thinking
about consciousness,
but the main issue is that you're not
testing in your brain,
you're testing or urine and a lot of
these neurotransmitters are biosynthesis
in the periphery,
so just because you have these
neurotransmitters in your urine doesn't
mean they were ever in your brain.
It doesn't say anything about anything,
so it's just,
it's so juvenile in a way.
It's such a.
it's such a piss poor way of maintaining
order,
checking people's
consciousness and make immediate.
What you should do is judge people based
on the productivity.
If I have some guy and he shows up work
and he kicks ass everyday,
I'm like,
dude,
what's your secret?
I get high.
Get high before work.
It's great.
I feel good having a good time at work.
Zippity Doo da Zippity Day.
I'm putting everything in order and it
just feels good.
Like keep doing what you're doing.
I mean that's how it should be.
We should be judged based on whether or
not whatever we're doing is.
I mean,
I guess
the real
caveat to bed would be people that do
speed.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
you get pretty productive for a short
period of time doing speed,
but I think the downside of that,
there's so many people that are on
adderall today.
Right?
What,
what are your feelings on that?
I think that it's a very interesting
issue because it's amazing when you look
at the history of all these things,
have these issues repeat themselves over
and over and over again.
So it was a problem in the fifties and
it's a problem in the sixties and it's a
problem in the seventies.
Now it's a problem now.
It's always a problem that we're
treating as if it were a new thing,
but people have been using amphetamines,
stimulants for the better part of 100
years.
And um,
people will now the kind of popular
thing to say is,
you know,
didn't you know,
adderall is one carbon atom away from
meth.
But here's the flip side.
Meth is one carbon away from adderall.
So this whole idea that math,
again,
back to pharmacological determinism,
that meth is a drug that turns you into
a toothless,
insane white trash guys stabbing the
walls with the cleaver.
Looking for people that are hiding and
whispering secret messages or something
like that,
like this is just a stereotype that we
have created.
Of course there are people like that,
but the reality is that these stimulants
have an ambiguous potential for all
sorts of things.
Some people use low doses of
methamphetamine,
in fact,
a schedule too because to this day it
can be and is prescribed as a treatment
for Adhd in addition to amphetamine,
which is adderall.
What do they call it when they
prescribe?
It does and is the brand name for
methamphetamine?
Uh,
adderall is the brand name fettuccine
and their vet and I've tried both drugs,
both amphetamine and methamphetamine and
they're very,
very similar drugs.
And that's not to say that either are
good or bad,
it's just a factual statement that if in
a double blind placebo controlled or not
even placebo control just a double blind
trial,
I don't think that I could,
it could differentiate.
It could also help obese patients lose
weight.
Did you know that?
Um,
there's a lot of people who think trump
is on diet pills.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
On a diagonal appropriate.
Yeah,
right.
and that he used to be on one of the,
one of the elements of fen phen phen
phen,
fenfluramine phentermine.
Well,
there was a,
some journalists that we even talked
about the DOJ.
We saved this.
We have it on a folder now.
Would you say,
Jamie?
I've been hit up messages about that.
Journalists,
that he might be sketchy,
sketchy or something like that,
but even if he were on [inaudible] or
fenfluramine or phentermine or fen
metrazole or any of these substances.
So what,
you know,
the question is,
is judgment compromised because he's
hopped up on speed,
was judgment seems compromised
regardless that?
Is that why?
No,
probably not,
but it could be why he gets so much shit
done.
I mean,
you remember when during the you,
you're,
you just don't want to compliment them.
And I understand that.
No,
no,
that's not why it's again,
it's this idea.
There's a certain exculpatory value that
drugs have.
People make the same arguments about
Hitler.
Hitler,
he was just high on speed that explains
it.
The Nazis,
they were just high on speed.
That explains it.
But what value does it really have?
The same thing with Anthony Bordain.
They'll say,
oh no,
drugs were found in his system.
Postmortem.
So what?
What if they had been then what?
Well,
the idea is that he might have been
experiencing a fucked up state of mind
because of some drug that made him make
a poor choice and take his own life.
But you wouldn't know.
You wouldn't know why he did it.
Is that what you're saying?
It wouldn't explain anything really
because you still wouldn't know his
internal state.
It would just be you're projecting an
assumption.
So what if there were a small amount of
heroin in his blood at the time of his
death,
then you would assume that he had
relapsed,
was so ashamed of his relapse that he
then decided to kill himself.
But the reality is we can't make those
sorts of assessments.
We don't know other people's internal
states.
We don't even know what these things do
to other people.
We don't.
But we do know that some things like
abilify and some other Ssri eyes and
even some anti anxiety medication had
been strongly linked to suicidal
thoughts and in fact there were actually
listed as some side effects for a lot of
these drugs.
Yes.
But when you think that.
I mean,
I know correlation does not equal
causation,
but don't you think that that's worth
considering and it's something to be
discussed.
It's worth considering,
but I would be careful about assigning
too much value to it,
which is what people tend to do the same
thing with columbine.
They'll say,
oh,
he was on that antidepressant.
That's why is it?
Why does it really explain it?
Because a hell of a lot
of people that take those same drugs and
don't kill all of their classmates.
Right,
right.
For sure.
But it also could be a factor and this
is not something that I think we should
avoid considering.
I think it should be discussed.
Yes,
I agree with you,
but I think we're trying to look at
things binary,
right?
We're looking at things in terms of like
on or off black or white.
One or zero and I,
I just don't think drugs work that way.
No,
and I think you agree.
Yeah.
The speed thing is curious to me because
one of the side effects of these drugs
is impulsive,
irrational behavior and extreme
confidence in oneself.
Like this is,
this is right.
This is what we always think of people
that are hopped up on speed.
People that have a coke confidence,
you know,
confidence is a real phenomenon.
When people do cocaine,
they feel very confident about
themselves and they save ridiculous shit
to people.
So the question is,
is that really what's happening?
If they have I gave coke to you,
would you start acting irrationally and
feeling extremely confident yourself?
Or is it just accentuating a problem
that already exists in the person's
personality?
Both.
Probably a combination of the two,
but the other thing is even if he has
been using this stuff for decades,
he's probably tolerant to it and it's
not.
I don't think it would explain his
behavior why thing is giving them
energy.
He's been like this for so long though.
This.
I mean,
this is a long history of this sort of
behavior.
Well,
this was what the journalist that talked
about that he had been on this stuff for
a long time and that there was a actual
Dwayne Reed pharmacy in New York where
he described where he got the
prescription filled.
People were doing the same thing with
his finasteride as well though,
and I found that particularly obnoxious
finasteride is pizza pizza.
So they were saying,
oh,
he's on finasteride and that explains,
you know,
is a fair or that explains this because
it does this or that to your libido.
And again,
it's like I don't know,
or not at all,
or let's give him some credit for being
a human being with freewill.
That makes choices on his own that
aren't entirely mediated by what
pharmaceuticals he uses.
Well,
finasteride also has side effects of
depression and we went over this
yesterday with my friend Ari who was
really depressed at one point in time
and it coincided with his use of
finasteride,
right?
Yeah.
I've seen,
but it's not very common.
It does occur,
but it's not uncommon.
Right.
But for the person that
does get those side effects,
saying that it's not common,
doesn't really offer any comfort.
No,
no.
Call.
Well,
I'm one of the lucky ones.
I'm one of the lucky ones,
ones that jump off a bridge to get my
hair to grow back.
But you know,
the reason that I'm so opinionated about
this particular issue is because you see
it time and time again.
It never stops.
You know?
I don't know if you're familiar with the
Jeffrey Macdonald murder case.
No,
I'm super fascinating.
You probably have read about it and
forgotten about it.
It was a big thing and maybe 1970,
but he was this military doctor,
um,
who's credentialed.
The perfect man.
Did everything right,
perfect family,
everything beautiful.
And then one night he goes to sleep and
claims that is right after the Manson
murders claims that these hippies walk
into the house saying,
kill the pigs.
Acid is groovy,
kill the pigs,
acid is groovy.
And then just brutally massacre his
entire family and out of nowhere,
out of nowhere.
Yes.
And um,
and it's a long and complicated story,
but he went to prison.
I don't think that he is guilty,
but people had to find an explanation
for why and you don't think he's guilty.
I don't think he's guilty.
He had no motive and there were an
investigation was botched and so you
think someone came into his house and
did that.
He was accused of but,
but because he had no motive,
people had to construct a motive.
They had to concoct a reason that this
doctor would have murdered his entire
family.
And so what's a good reason?
Oh,
amphetamine.
He'd been using this,
a amphetamine containing diet pills.
So that explains it all right.
But it doesn't,
it's a terrible explanation.
People use amphetamine all the time
without killing their family.
So I just want to be very careful about,
you know,
do these things play a role in human
behavior?
Of course they do,
but do they determine human behavior?
No.
That's a very good point.
There's a lot of factors.
There's just,
it's messy.
Being a person is missing.
It's very complicated.
I mean,
you're a different person at noon then
you are at 7:00
PM,
of course.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
it's just,
it's so complicated and the more
limitations we put on research and the
more stigma we put on the use of these
things,
the more murky these waters are going to
be.
Yeah,
and I think people don't even appreciate
the extent to which all these drugs have
been made illegal.
Of course,
everyone's where cannabis is a schedule
on LSD,
psilocybin,
Mtma,
but the list is long.
It's hundreds and hundreds of chemicals
and a lot of these chemicals are
chemicals with no supporters,
no one's fighting for them.
There's a substance called two cn,
one of shoguns creations.
They just threw it in schedule and no
one uses it.
If you scour the Internet,
I'd be surprised if you could find three
reports of people using to cn totally
unheard of,
but they just throw it in schedule one
because why the hell not.
No one's going to stand up for it.
That's the end of two CN.
But they miss a lot of shit too,
right?
Like they miss five methoxy muscle trip.
To me,
they missed that.
No,
that was made illegal in 2011.
Right?
For 1970 when everything else got thrown
into the mix,
they made it illegal.
I bought that shit.
Used to be able to buy it online.
Yeah,
so did I.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
You could buy a fucking jug of it then
get the whole city high buyadol online.
Yeah,
because it was never popular,
so how do they make it illegal?
How do they.
How do they do that?
They don't need any reason.
They can simply say that it has abuse
potential and make it illegal and if no
one opposes it,
then it becomes illegal.
That's how this list has gotten so long
that you have all these people fighting
for the legality of cannabis and these
other substances that are known to have
therapeutic potential,
but these other more obscure substances
that are really only a concern to
scientists who are very seriously
disinclined to break the law for the
sake of the research.
Drug users don't care about breaking the
law.
Scientists are very unlikely because the
whole purpose of science is to publish
and you can't publish if you committed a
crime in the context of your research,
so scientists are dramatically limited
by the prohibition of these substances
and it's the obscure ones that end up
actually making a big difference.
Not so much clinically,
but in terms of actually understanding
the mechanism of these substances,
the structure,
activity,
relationships,
the neuropharmacology yeah.
The,
the stigma on psychedelic use and and
even studying them has led so many
doctors or scientists,
researchers that would be inclined to
want to do research on these particular
things.
They avoid them because it could be
incredibly damaging to their careers and
it's bureaucratic.
I mean there was a group at Columbia
that was doing really fascinating
research on the drug Ibogaine and
Parkinson's disease and the.
I was speaking with the head of this
study and he was saying how obnoxious it
was to have the government common way.
His vial of Ibogaine every day and
monitors logs and you know,
this guy is a really serious researcher.
He's not gonna.
If you were to get high,
he's not going to get high off this tiny
supply of government mandated or
government sanctioned Ibogaine that was
supplied to him,
but uh,
but they give.
These people are really hard time.
They make them buy a very expensive
safe.
They do all this stuff that these are
the last people to abuse the substances
and they are the ones that are hurt the
most severely except for,
of course,
the people that go to prison,
they're the ones that are hurt the most
severely.
Yeah.
It's a crazy thing to think that people
are going to recreationally use
Ibogaine.
That's one of the weirder ones.
Oh,
it's totally bizarre.
Yeah.
And I'm.
And Ibogaine is a drug with so much
potential for those people that are
aware of.
I began.
It's typically only discussed as a drug
that treats addiction to opioids,
which is very,
very important,
especially now.
But that's the tip of the iceberg with
Ibogaine.
It has one of the most complex
pharmacology's of any drug I've ever
studied.
There's almost nothing it does not do.
I mean it's,
you know,
you have the Alpha three Beta four
nicotinic acetylcholine receptor,
which is also the target of Welbutrin
and has a kind of smoking cessation,
anti addictive effect.
Then you have really high affinity
relative to the other receptors for the
MMDA receptors,
so as academy and type effect and as a
classical psychedelic effect of the five
ht two a receptor.
Then it's a dopamine reuptake inhibitor,
Serotonin reuptake inhibitor.
It just goes on and then it releases
this protein bdnf,
which is considered one of the most
important proteins in treatment of
Parkinson's disease.
It's one of the only things that is able
to cause a regrowth of dopaminergic
neurons and people that have
Parkinson's.
So this is like really fascinating stuff
that's just in schedule one scientists
can't work with.
It is a tragedy.
It is a tragedy and it's also so
effective.
I know so many people that have gone to
Mexico and go into these clinics and
done one Ibogaine session for 24 hours
and come out of it.
A totally different person come out of
it with a complete new perspective on
even why they were using whatever they
were using in the first place in a way
that they didn't do.
Not only does it help eliminate the
addictive properties and the connection
that your body has to those substances,
but it also allows you to reexamined why
you went down that road in the first
place.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And there was a sort of pharmaceutical
push to develop non psychedelic
derivatives of Ibogaine that would
retain the anti addictive properties,
which sounds like a good idea in theory,
but so they created this drug called 18
mc and it wasn't psychedelic,
but then it also lacked some of these
neurotrophic factor releasing properties
of Ibogaine.
But really the bottom line is that we
shouldn't deny the fact that the
psychedelic activity of these substances
is therapeutic psychotherapeutic in and
of itself.
You know,
I had a friend who was severely,
severely addicted to heroin and he
traveled to the Netherlands to take
Ibogaine and,
you know,
took the drug,
was going into the experience and then
started feeling this intense craving for
heroin.
And um,
and started looking through his bags to
see if he somehow had forgotten about a
little bit of heroin that could just get
them through the day.
And then he goes into his bag and then
finds a small bag of heroin and snorts
it.
And then it's like,
I traveled all the way to the
Netherlands to do this.
This was,
I'm a failure.
I'm relapsing after all of this money,
all this work.
I have no self control.
I'm a terrible,
terrible person.
Why can't I just stop and then realize
that the whole thing was a holy nation.
There was no heroin.
He hallucinated his own relapse.
Whoa.
Wow.
What was your experience with the ivory
game?
I've never taken high doses.
The most I've ever taken is 50
milligrams of this ineffective dose.
It really depends.
There's sort of move toward microdosing
Ibogaine because it actually does have a
cardio toxic effect,
especially at higher doses.
So people are looking into ways of
reducing that cardio toxicity by using
it at lower doses for longer periods of
time.
Again,
this is something that has to do with
prohibition because in a this
prohibition market,
if you are addicted to heroin,
you go to Mexico or you go to Canada and
you go to an Ibogaine clinic,
you need to get as much bang for your
buck as quickly as possible.
You're not going to stay there for two
months of treatment because most people
have lives and can't afford to do that.
So do you.
Do they give you what,
what is called a flood dose?
It's a massive dose off,
often a multi gram dose of Ibogaine
because it's just like a sledge hammer
that knocks you down and allows you to
get out of it.
But is that the best way?
That's the fastest way.
That's the most appetizing way for
someone that had to travel to do it,
but is it the best?
Probably not because we know that at
high doses it has this potential to
induce cardiac arrhythmias and that can
kill and has killed.
So people are now looking at lower doses
over longer periods of time.
Which would be ideal if it were legal in
the United States,
I believe.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a really interesting one.
To me it's a,
it's a really interesting one because
it's got such a long history of use and
so many people have had these very good
experiences with getting off of
addictive drugs from it.
Oh yeah.
And so relatively unknown as well.
It's something that,
you know,
talk to someone like you and of course
you know about it,
but I bet if we walk down the street and
asked 100 people,
I'd be shocked if one of them knew about
it.
Yeah.
And you know,
Terence Mckenna would sometimes talk
about silicide been as an invention of
mushrooms or is technology or as being
synthetic and uh,
I don't really agree with that idea of
an invention of mushrooms where he would
sort of say like,
this is a synthetic as a coca cola
bottle.
This is like alien technology.
That's how you would describe
psilocybin.
But in my opinion it's,
you know,
it's a pretty simple derivative of trip
to fan.
You just decarboxylated methalate the
nitrogen twice and then add this
phosphate Ester,
but,
but Ibogaine,
that's a crazy molecule.
That's like a three dimensional thing
that no medicinal chemists would have
ever discovered that if there's,
you know,
not to sound mystical,
but that strikes me as some sort of
plant technology.
I mean,
it's an amazingly complicated structure.
It's so complicated that it's almost
impossible to synthesize.
In fact,
it can't be synthesized commercially.
All the Ibogaine that people use has to
be extracted from plants because that's
the only way to get it.
Wow.
Um,
I first found out about it when,
when hunter s Thompson accused Ed Muskie
of being on it during the presidential,
uh,
race of,
what was it,
1970 or whatever it was.
Um,
that was a hilarious moment and a lot of
people I think were introduced to what
Ibogaine was by that when he said a
Brazilian,
which Dr had been flown in.
Of course it doesn't even grow in
Brazil,
but yeah,
it doesn't even make sense.
It's also,
it was hilarious when he was on the Dick
Cavett show and they asked him about
spreading those rumors and he's like,
well,
there was a rumor,
uh,
that,
he was doing this a Ibogaine.
And,
uh,
I know because I started the rumor,
I just reported factually,
there was a rumor,
I mean it's,
uh,
there's,
there's a,
a lot
of these drugs that get put into various
categories and Ibogaine is one of the
very few that really isn't in any
category in terms of like modern
culture,
like the way we discuss and consider
these things because it's very different
structurally and logically.
But that the hunter s Thompson story is
really interesting because it's
obviously a very charming,
funny story and I'd have to know exactly
when it happened relative to the
scheduling of Ibogaine,
but that might be an example of how,
what's a frivolous joke that most people
enjoy told in the wrong climate can
result in the loss of a chemical that
could be good,
that could save tens of thousands of
lives and could be a treatment for
Parkinson's disease.
You know,
this is the responsibility that
journalists have.
It's more responsibility than I think
they'd like to have often.
But that's the truth.
You make a joke about Ibogaine.
Next thing you know,
it's in schedule one.
Maybe he made the joke afterwards,
but if he didn't have to wonder because
that was one of the first major mentions
of Ibogaine in the popular press and the
same is true of,
you know,
there was a rolling stone scare article
that came out a while ago and it same
deal with this drug to ct seven and they
do a whole story,
oh,
this teenager,
he took too much and this to ct seven,
it can kill you with just a little pile
of powder or whatever.
And uh,
and then the drug is made schedule one
shogun worked on psychedelics.
Alexander Shogun,
great medicinal chemist who spent his
entire life studying psychedelics
considered this one of the sixth
greatest creations of his entire career
squashed by a single stupid story in
rolling stone.
That's how easily it happens.
That was the story.
Stupid.
I mean,
did it have any basis?
In fact,
an editor at rolling stone told me that
there were factual errors in it and
there's something weird about it,
but yes,
people did die because yes,
people die from using drugs occasionally
to deny that would be to lie,
but that doesn't mean that they don't
have therapeutic activity and it doesn't
mean that they should be illegal.
One of the ones that disturbs me the
most is fentanyl.
Fentanyl,
just.
I don't even understand why anybody
would want to make that.
It seems to me that we have no one of
opiates as it is.
Why make one that's a thousand times
stronger than heroin?
Yeah.
I've known for fentanyl chemists,
including the one that introduced
fentanyl to the United States initially.
He died recently.
Did he die from it?
No one died of old age.
He's killed so many people.
Yeah.
Tom Petty.
David Bowie,
Bowie one.
I'm not sure.
Prince.
Yeah.
I'm mean.
There's quite a few great people that
we've lost to this stuff.
Yeah,
it's really.
It's unfortunate,
but again,
fentanyl is not the problem.
The problem is people taking it and the
problem is lack of access to safer
opioids and lack of education
surrounding fentanyl because it doesn't
even really have desirable properties.
You know,
one thing that people always talk about,
the potency offense and on one thing
that they don't often talk about is the
duration.
It's a very,
very short duration opioid which
necessitates compulsive,
constant,
re dosing.
If you're addicted to fentanyl,
unless you're doing a transdermal patch
or something like that,
you typically can't make it through a
single night without having to reduce
because the duration is so short.
That's why it's always done in these
prolonged release formulations like a
lollipop that you suck or a patch,
but anyway,
it's.
Yeah,
It's not a drug that's well suited to
street use.
It's to the therapeutic index is too
narrow.
It's duration is too short.
It has a medical purpose that it works
very well for.
It shouldn't be used as a heroine
replacement,
but the economic reality is that you
have to make heroin from opium,
opium,
s that come from a place where poppies
are grown.
That's a whole process.
Whereas fentanyl can be made by one guy
somewhere and the profit margin on the
fentanyl is so much greater that there's
an enormous economic incentive and the
first chemist,
this guy that was sort of a friend of
mine that died to do it,
considered it a good thing to do.
That's the complexity that you have to
recognize it so easy to say that all of
these people are so bad,
but often you don't know what's going to
happen until it happens.
His idea was that one of the major
burdens of being addicted to heroin is
that you can't afford it.
It's really expensive,
so by substituting this relatively
inexpensive material,
the price of heroin would go down.
This financial burden associated with
opioid addiction would be reduced.
It would actually improve the quality of
life of the users,
and it could even be a more pure,
potentially safer material.
If you look at certain literature,
of course that's not what happened,
and many people died and he went to
prison as a result of it.
Did it really?
Yes.
Why don't he go to prison for it?
Because people died and it was traced
back to him.
Wow.
Yeah,
so he wasn't doing this in any
sanctioned?
No.
He was a clandestine chemist.
His name was George Marquardt.
Weird guy.
Yeah.
Yes.
But anyway,
you know,
you just don't know.
You don't know what's going to happen
until it happens.
You know,
of course,
the legendary story that heroin was
introduced by Bayer as a nonaddictive
alternative to morphine.
They probably did think that was the
case at the beginning,
but history has shown that that is not
the case.
That's one of the problems with
introducing any drug to a large
population.
You simply don't know.
It's and it's also one of the things
that I find most interesting in and
perhaps a silver lining in this whole
synthetic cannabinoid narrative that's
been playing out over the last decade is
you could say,
oh,
it's terrible.
People should just smoke cannabis,
but we're learning so much about what
cannabinoid receptor agonists can do
that we would have never learned if it
weren't for the widespread use of
synthetic cannabinoids.
I mean,
just for instance,
that it is possible for high potency,
so cannabinoid receptor agonist to kill
you,
that's a big one.
We didn't know that until recently that
they can be addictive.
We didn't know that.
What are they using,
what is it?
It's so.
It's an impressively diverse array of
chemicals.
You know,
it started out with a drug called CP 55,
9:40,
then it was cp a,
what they call it,
cannibis cycle of hex and all now and
then Jwh jwh 73,
jwh 2:10
on and on and on and on.
And then it just branched like a giant
cannabinoid fractal in every imaginable
imaginable direction.
And uh,
and a lot of these compounds,
you know,
they,
they were patented by various
pharmaceutical companies like Pfizer for
therapeutic purposes.
Again,
this wasn't some level and chemist who's
cackling and saying,
ha ha ha.
I figured out the most addictive thing
possible.
They were just looking to see what's
legal,
what looks pretty potent and reasonably
safe.
Okay,
we'll make that,
we'll sell it.
And uh,
and I've spoken with the chemists that
actually were behind a lot of these
operations.
Again,
not bad guys necessarily,
they,
you know,
typically people don't want to hurt
other people.
You know,
genuine,
villainous people are pretty rare in my
experience.
Most people believe that what they're
doing has a justification that is good.
And again,
with the synthetic cannabinoid ideas,
one is that although you won't hear this
in the popular press and it's rarely
said they can be very enjoyable and it
would be dishonest to say otherwise,
some of them are very euphoric and
compare favorably to cannabis and in
certain measures might even be superior.
That doesn't mean they're safer.
It just means that there's something
very desirable but them,
and if you deny that,
then you neglect to understand why
people use them in the first place,
which is that they make you feel good.
So that's part of it.
But then the other thing is the urine
testing,
people wanting to be able to get high
without breaking the law,
low cost.
I mean there's a lot of motivations for
doing this and as it played out,
people died.
People became addicted and random things
that no one would have ever expected
occurred.
We learned,
here's another silver lining.
I'm sure you're familiar with cannabis
hyperemesis syndrome.
No,
not,
you know,
this,
um,
this is our pattern that certain people
that smoke all day every day,
um,
it started showing up in the medical
literature about a decade ago.
People smoke all day every day and they
start getting very,
very nauseous and vomiting.
And the only thing that can relieve the
vomiting is a hot shower.
Huh?
So really weird.
So all these people are showing up in
emergency rooms when they run out of hot
water.
I'm saying like,
I need some kind of a,
I need some help or something like,
I don't know what's going on.
The condition resolves itself very
rapidly as soon as you stopped smoking
cannabis.
So it's not hard to treat.
You can't smoke weed anymore,
but no one knew what caused it and why
it was happening now after thousands of
years of human cannabis interaction.
Why now for the first time in history?
And the answer is that people are
smoking more weed now than ever before.
You know,
the levels of thc ingestion with dabbing
and high potency strains are just higher
for some people,
it's much higher than it's ever been in
the past.
But um,
but then the question is,
what is causing it?
Is it the cannabis itself is a
fertilizer,
is it a pesticide?
What is responsible for this?
And it wasn't until people were using
synthetic cannabinoids began to
experience the same constellation of
symptoms that they realized that this is
an intrinsic property of certain
cannabinoid receptor agonists.
So that's something that you can learn
from all of this,
that it wasn't pesticides and it wasn't
some kind of a fungus or something like
that girl on the planet,
but this is something that happens from
prolonged high dose use of cannabinoids.
And there's all sorts of other lessons
that can be learned.
Is that an issue with cannabis use?
Pesticides?
Have you ever heard of people having
real problem with this?
It was certainly,
you know,
paraquat pot.
Did you ever hear what's that?
Paraquat was,
um,
you know,
in one of many misguided attempts to
prevent people from using drugs,
they started spraying all of the
cannabis.
It was grown in Mexico with this ultra
toxic herbicide called paraquat and this
is a drug that induces Parkinson's
disease when you're exposed to it,
like really seriously nasty stuff.
No joke.
And so the idea was if we poison all the
cannabis and create this widespread fear
that whatever you're smoking might
contain paraquat,
maybe people will use it less.
And Luckily paraquat is a,
doesn't have a lot of thermo stability.
It's sort of denatured by the heat of
smoking.
So it's argued that people were not
actually exposed to it,
who smoked it,
but still this is a horrendous thing for
the government to have done.
They did the same thing during alcohol
prohibition by the way they would poison
alcohol.
I mean that's the extent they'll poison
people to prevent them from getting
high.
But um,
that's a reality.
But,
but now in turn,
you know,
there's obviously a move toward organic
gardening people using,
you know,
neem oil and things like that.
So I wouldn't know.
I'll go in.
There was,
yeah,
there was actually a big controversy in
Colorado with a pesticide called Mike
Club.
You tennille I believe that was used.
And potentially could release cyanide
when smoked.
So
yes.
Yeah.
Why would worry about that with large
scale production things become
commercially viable.
The point where someone like rj reynolds
gets into the mix and starts growing
enormous marijuana plantations.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's a concern with all the food
that we eat as well.
Of course.
Yeah.
What is interesting to you now?
Like is there anything that's coming up
or some new thing that people aren't,
might not be aware of that might be
fascinating to you?
Yeah,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm interested in everything.
You know,
I,
I love the history.
I love,
um,
you know,
I did a piece in this last season of my
tv show or I traced the history of
Psychedelic toad venom of five Meo dmt
containing toad venom because people
have this idea that all psychedelics
have been used for thousands of years
that every psychedelic an ancient
history.
But when you look at the history of five
Meo DMT,
there is no evidence.
Really no convincing evidence that I'm
aware of.
Maybe you can point to a ceramic toad is
that evidence that people smoke toad
venom?
Not In my opinion,
it might be some indication that maybe
they did,
but it's certainly not hard evidence.
Even if there were a guy sitting on his
back smoking a pipe,
it wouldn't be hard evidence.
But anyway,
so there isn't convincing evidence as
far as I'm concerned of ancient toad I'm
used.
So then the question is,
when did it start?
Who was the first person to do this?
And I,
I love these little historical
investigations to get to the bottom.
Who is the first person to synthesize
this drug?
What were their intentions?
Who's the first person to smoke?
Toad venom.
And the total volume is a weird one too,
because there's this bizarre
misconception that you lick the toads.
Right?
Which again,
journalistically produced,
maybe it was inspired by cartoons as
well to some extent,
but I.
Yes.
So the way you do it is you have to get
the tow to excrete whatever this is and
you put it on glass and then you dry it
out.
Is that the idea?
That's the idea.
Yes.
And then you scrape it off with a razor
blade and then smoke it.
That's it.
And does it come,
is it a pure form of five Meo DMT?
No,
and there's actually very little
chemical analysis that's been done in
the 21st century.
I analyzed a sample that I collected
when I was in Sonora and it contained in
addition to five Meo dmt.
It contained some interesting serotonin
derivatives including serotonin sulfate
and nobody knows how these different
tryptamine components as well as these
steroidal lactones that are sometimes
called bufo talks and contribute to the
experience.
If I had to guess,
probably not that much,
but maybe there's a little bit of that
sort of entourage effect that you get
with almost any plant that has a variety
of different alkaloids that might
inhibit certain enzymes or do this or
that.
Um,
but it's about 15 percent according to
the older literature.
The analysis that I did wasn't
quantitative,
so I don't know exactly what the
concentration was,
but it's somewhere in that region.
And I'm sure it depends on whether the
toad has been milked previously and all
these other variables.
Does the experience mirror taking
synthetic five meo dmt?
I haven't tried.
I've tried synthetic five mud empty a
couple times.
I've tried boof,
all various venom wanted a low dose once
at a high dose.
There were all different,
but then everything is different.
Mushrooms are different.
Every time I take them,
you know,
it's,
it's really hard once you start
explaining a different experience based
on the composition of the material
because how do you assign it to the dose
or the minute number of different
tryptamines that are also present.
It's really hard to say,
but you know,
I think that there is a strong argument
to be made for using the synthetic as
opposed to the pto drive materials
simply because you don't have to harm or
hurt.
Not that it necessarily does harm toads,
but you don't even have to risk it and
it's easy to synthesize.
Yeah,
I'm sure it.
Toads aren't into getting rubbed on
windshields.
Yeah.
Similar to annoying day for a toad.
They want to eat insects.
Yeah.
Whatever the fuck they do.
Um,
one of the more interesting stories out
of the last decade or so was,
um,
this
story that I read about these scholars
in Jerusalem,
that we're connecting the story of Moses
in the burning Bush to the Acacia Bush
and the case should tree which is rich
and dmt and they believe that,
you know,
when you're talking about a story that
was told through oral traditions for who
knows how many years and then written
down in ancient Hebrew and then
transcribed and you know,
and translated to Greek and Latin and
all these days there's a lot lost in the
mix.
And they believed that,
what that story might have been about of
Moses coming down from Mount Sinai with
the tablets and having the experience
with meeting God in a burning Bush.
This is in fact was a dimethyltryptamine
experience.
Maybe.
Yeah.
A,
it's a big.
Maybe it's a big.
Maybe I can say that.
Um,
if you go to the south of Mexico in
Chiapas,
there's a tree that grows.
There is a weed called Mimosa hostility.
Maybe you're familiar with it.
And this is so abundant that it's used
to make fence posts.
All the fences on the side of the road
are made of most of hostility.
It's used as firewood to cook meals.
The air smells like dmt because people
are using it as fuel all over the place.
Not a single person that I spoke with
was aware that it with psychoactive.
And these are people that are burning it
all the time.
Do they get high from it?
Is there like if you were in a tent or
something like that,
you were doing a hot box sort of
scenario,
would you get high from it?
No,
I saw no.
Would you?
It may be.
It's about two percent dmt so you'd
probably have to get so sick from
coughing and yeah,
it would be a very.
I mean even just smoking pure crystal
Dmt,
it can be very difficult for some
people.
So my gas not to be like a wet blanket,
but my guess is not really.
Um,
and that's a very strong source.
As strong as maybe there's some acacia
stronger,
but that's certainly comparable.
And that's something people are using to
cook food all the time and they're not
aware that it's like,
so was there a way or is there a way for
a person living thousands of years ago
to somehow or another extract dmt from
something like the Acacia Tree?
Um,
that's actually spent some time thinking
about that a while ago.
It would be,
first of all,
depends on how you define extraction.
If it were to in like an Iowasca sends
like a tea,
of course,
yes.
But then they would need some sort of
enzyme inhibitor to create the.
If it were to create a,
an isolated smokable form again,
you know,
you could just do it like an aqueous
infusion and then try that out and maybe
smoke that.
But in terms of like a real extraction
that would produce crystals of DMT,
I don't know what the non polar solvent
they would be using to extract a
freebase.
Would it be like butter or something.
And then how would you get rid of the
butter?
So what is the process like?
If you're going to take a tree that's
rich and DMT and extract dmt from it,
what do you have to use a.
have you ever done it before?
No,
I've never done it.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
it's um,
it's a very generalizable and simple
process that applies to almost
everything in chemistry.
It's,
you know,
sometimes it's called an acid base
extraction.
Most people that are in the dmt
community go something they call
straight to base and the,
you know,
the idea is that the side chain of the
dmt molecule contains a basic nitrogen
that if it's protonated in an acidic
solution than it's water soluble and if
it's deprotonated than it's only soluble
in a non polar solvent.
So what you do is you just deprotonated
the nitrogen with a base potassium
hydroxide or sodium hydroxide typically,
and then treat that aqueous basic
solution with a non polar solvent like
Nafa and isolate the Nafa,
dry it out and you have your material.
And that applies to everything.
That's not a dmt specific process,
but that's what people do.
Everything with the basic nitrogen.
Now,
what's the earliest history of
extraction that we will,
you know,
the first wave of DMT use in the United
States was all synthetic.
In fact,
DMT was discovered synthetically before
it was ever found in nature.
The same is true of five mg.
Odm called.
They do that.
There was a Canadian chemist named
Richard Hellmuth Mansky who,
um,
I believe was looking at different
alkaloids and strawberry plants and he
was synthesizing references for these
potential strawberry alkaloids and made
dmt so he didn't know what he had made
other than a potential natural product
found in strawberries.
And um,
and then it wasn't until much later
conducted self experiments with injected
dmt that people became fully aware of
its psychoactivity.
And then people started finding it
implants.
I mean the,
the 19 fifties where like,
uh,
an early sixties were of course a
fascinating time in psychedelic research
because you have these convergences of
these amazing ideas.
First you have the discovery of
Serotonin,
which is like,
you know,
we take this for granted,
now it's in television commercials,
but this was of course something that no
one knew about it.
And suddenly they're finding this in all
kinds of different animals.
Initially it was in the salivary glands
of squid and I'm in different animals.
Then they're finding it in the human
intestine.
Then they're also finding that all of
these plants that people worshiped in
various indigenous societies also
contain serotonin molecules.
Then they discover lsd and find that
that's maybe the most potent known
pharmacological agent at that time.
And it binds to serotonin receptors.
It activates a Serotonin type response
in isolated tissue.
So there's like this weird triple
convergence of information.
Super potent,
amazing compound LSD is discovered,
Serotonin is discovered and all these
different organisms.
And there's a pharmacological
convergence between the two of them.
And then you have all these people
worshiping serotonin molecules.
So there was,
you know,
a lot of enthusiasm at that time to
figure all this out.
So in terms of history,
so we're talking about somewhere in the
19 fifties they started extracting tmt.
The use of it orally dates back far
longer than that because of use of Mao
inhibitors and creating Iowasca.
But in terms of the first extraction,
we can kind of implants to smoke.
It might've been even later.
It might've been in the eighties.
Okay.
So the idea that people thousands of
years ago,
we're able to do something along those
lines is probably probably not accurate
because because they're talking about a
burning Bush.
That's why it's appealing to people.
Right.
The idea of Moses d,
do you think that maybe the
understanding of synthesis from the
synthesizing this from these scholars,
maybe they don't have enough of an
understanding of chemistry?
Well,
what would be really interesting is to
do an experiment to see what were the
materials that were available.
How would this have been done?
Would you have to use butter as your non
polar solvent?
How well would that work?
What would your butter preparation be
done when you put it?
Would you take it rectally then?
Is that how it would work?
I mean you have to kind of.
What would your base have been?
They were talking about it being
something from burning a burning Bush.
Maybe it's just one of those things that
sort of gets conflated,
right?
Because you have people today that are
very aware that people smoked dmt and
have these incredibly intense religious
psychedelic experiences,
and then maybe they looked at the acacia
bushes and said,
oh,
the acacia bushes rich and DMT.
That's probably where the Moses story
came from.
Right.
Well,
what's really interesting is,
you know,
dmt has never been found in the human
brain,
even though Rick strassman says that it
has been.
So.
A lot of people are constantly assigning
altered states of consciousness to Dmt,
but we can have these states without
dmt.
I mean,
maybe it's never been found in the human
brain,
but also there's ethical and
experimental issues with sampling fluid
from the living human brain.
Right,
but it has.
They have founded in living rats were
fairly recently.
This is the cottonwood research
foundation.
That's their.
Their.
Their attempt is to try to prove that
the pineal gland is a source for DMT.
We know that DMT exists in the human
body.
We know that the liver produces it,
and we know that the lungs produce it.
We're not totally aware of whether or
not there's anecdotal evidence that
points to the pineal gland
based on the rat idea and based on the
presence of certain enzymes that could
be responsible for it,
but even if it is,
even if it is,
then what,
there's still a whole question of how is
it released,
how is it distributed,
what receptors does it activate in?
Is it even necessary as an explanation
for altered states of consciousness?
Because there are other things in the
brain other than dmt.
DMT has never even been found in the
brain,
but there are other things,
you know,
you have endogenous proteins that bind
to the kappa opioid receptor,
the same receptor that is responsible
for the effect of Salvia,
um,
things like that.
They were responsible.
I mean,
even carbon dioxide itself can induce a
pretty strong altered state of
consciousness.
Right.
Which is why people like those
psychedelic breathing exercises.
Yeah.
Sort of.
Was it like hypoxic?
Is that what it is?
What are they doing when they have
those?
Um,
the what,
what is it called?
There's a type of breathing exercise
that induces psychedelic states.
Holotropic breathwork.
Yeah,
and that is the idea behind that,
right?
It increases the amount of carbon
dioxide in your blood.
I haven't seen it.
A mechanistic explanation.
Hm.
Yeah.
I think that was,
but it would,
yeah,
it would make sense.
In an early LSD psychotherapy,
one of the things that they would do
before giving someone lsts would give
them something called carbogen,
which was a gas that contains carbon
dioxide and they would look at their
response to the carbon dioxide
inhalation and if it induced a panic
response,
they would say,
maybe you're not psychologically ready
for this lsd.
That's scary.
So that was.
You're talking about a test.
I mean that was a very primitive early
tests that was used by psychiatrists to
see if people were had this
psychological fortitude to withstand the
experience.
That's fascinating.
So tell me more about whatever is in the
brain that mirrors the effects of
Salvia.
It's a protein.
I can't remember off the top of my head.
What did you look up?
Endogenous ligand for Kappa opioid
receptor.
It will come up.
David Nichols recently wrote a paper
that actually goes into alternate
mechanisms of how the DMT type a near
death experience could be produced by
non dmt compounds,
but I mean,
you know,
there was a lot of work also on
endogenous and MDA receptor antagonists.
There was a a protein that was called
Alpha endo psychosis or Angel Dustin
named after Angel Dust,
but the main researcher died in a car
accident,
like right as he was making some kind of
breakthrough breakthrough supposedly,
but I'm q spooky music,
but you know,
there's all.
This has been a longstanding question in
psychiatry is you know,
what causes psychosis,
what causes altered states of
consciousness?
Is there an endogenous psychedelic?
That was one of the major motivations
for a lot of this research in the
sixties.
Finding the endogenous psychotic and
that is responsible for schizophrenia.
Now it doesn't seem to be the case,
but it's still a question that comes up.
What if dopamine is methylated in a
certain way to create diamonds?
Oxy Fin ethylamine or what about this?
What about that?
I mean,
sheldon was very interested in it,
but the metabolic production of various
psychedelics that account for altered
states of consciousness,
it just hasn't been supported by
evidence in a very strong way,
even though people really find the idea
compelling and there was also the 5
million dmt and schizophrenia people's
crn.
That's also a thing,
right?
And we know that the body does produce
five Meo DMT.
We just don't know where yet,
because again,
it's like what I was saying earlier
about the depression tests where you
look at your urine,
so you find five Meo dmt in your urine.
And your first assumption might be,
okay,
there's five immuno DMT in my body.
It was in my brain,
but you don't know that it could have
been biosynthesis in your intestine and
it could have been excluded without ever
entering your brain.
Right?
This is the whole idea of monoamine
oxidase,
right?
The idea that when we're eating things
that are rich and DMT,
monoamine oxidase is breaking it down in
the gut.
Yeah.
So even if you're consuming something.
So if something is.
So how do they know that this,
this,
uh,
Salvia like substance
exists in the mind or in the brain
rather because this,
this peptide or protein has been
isolated.
Do you find the name of it?
Oh,
okay.
How I caught four of those words.
You said I've lost what I was supposed
to be.
Um,
so we know there's a host of different
psychoactive substance are absolutely
produced by the body and in,
in,
in the,
in the brain,
and that there's different ways that
human beings have been able to achieve
psychedelic states outside of consuming
drugs.
Have you
done that?
I've done lucid dreaming things.
I've done Kundalini Yoga
and one is the one that I'm most
interested in because I have someone
who's,
a friend of mine that got really into it
and he was saying that he can achieve
very dmt like state
know is a really interesting aspect of
all of this that isn't often discussed,
which is the ability to have these
states and still interact with your
environment.
Because of course there's something very
physically taxing about breath of fire.
These Kundalini breathing techniques,
if you induce an altered state of
consciousness,
you need to be focused and you need to
be in a specific place sitting down
where psychedelics have this amazing
ability to allow you to have that
experience,
but walk around and I think that's not
to be underestimated,
the walking around because then you can
really reexamine your environment.
That's a big part of it.
For me,
a big part of the psychedelic experience
is seeing what is New York like,
what do I like or not like about New
York?
What do I like or not like about my
apartment?
These matters.
These things matter.
This is your environment.
Do you want to be surrounded by clutter
that you don't like?
If you don't get rid of it?
These are the sorts of thoughts you
have,
and this is my other issue with going to
the Peruvian Amazon to have a
psychedelic experience because if you do
it in this place that is superficially
inappropriate,
like your apartment,
I think it has the most applicability to
your own existence in terms of the music
you listened to,
your friends,
your environment,
your life,
you're confronted by the books that you
read,
the photos of the people that,
you know,
all the things that matter to you.
Not a jungle,
although jungles are very beautiful and
visually stimulating and I'm sure and
our,
I know an amazing place to use
psychedelics.
Um,
I think that we underestimate the value
of these things have been integrated
into a more normal type of experience
and that's something you can't do as
easily with a Kundalini.
Right,
right.
That makes sense.
So when you're using psychedelics,
you will use them and walk around New
York City?
Yes.
What does that look?
Um,
I often feel a lot of love for.
Really?
Yeah.
Which is,
you know,
because I think that we also tend to get
into these very angry,
the subways,
knowing guys taking up too much room.
I have to stand taking forever.
It smells weird,
whatever.
Everyone is looking at their phones all
the time,
which is a little bit dark.
Um,
and then you know,
if you're on a low dose of a psychedelic
or even a higher one,
sometimes I'll look at everyone on their
phones and I'll just feel compassion and
love and think like what a strange
situation we've all gotten ourselves
into.
I love all these people and it's like,
I don't know what to say about it,
but I understand that completely and I
don't know where we're going from here.
And he suddenly feel connected to
something that's very real,
which is people on the subway not
looking at each other anymore.
I mean,
this is in my own life.
Something that has changed dramatically
when I moved to New York.
No one looked at phones.
Now people only look at phones.
Everyone is looking at phones the entire
time they're on the subway is a total
change in human behavior.
And you really start thinking about
things like that and it matters because
it's not in the Amazon,
it's your life and these are the things
that choices that you make.
Are you going to be a person that looks
at their phone all day
time as well?
Yeah.
It's fascinating how quickly that took
hold.
Yeah.
If you look at human history,
when the iphone is 10 years old,
I know that's really when it started,
so 10 years ago,
people's.
And even then in the beginning of the
iphone there were fucking useless,
right?
You know,
you get online and it was really slow
and terrible and so most of the time we
just text messages,
but now with all the apps and social
media and constant constant updates of
information and new things and new
events and new trends and it's just.
It's always calling you.
I'm going to check,
make sure everything's done.
We've been on this podcast for two
hours.
Let me see what's going on.
I'll look at that.
All of these messages here,
you did it to me.
Actually.
I have this vivid memory of standing at
your front door and you selling twitter
to me saying like,
Oh,
you've got it.
You've got to use twitter.
It's amazing.
People send all thing you all these
articles and it's so useful.
You learn so much.
It's a really amazing set of only had
one tweet at that time and now it's like
2,500
tweets later and hundreds of hours of my
life.
I'll never get it.
Sorry.
I got Ya.
Got Ya.
Um,
it w,
it is that way still for me in many
ways.
I learn a lot about what's going on in
the world and I follow a lot of science
tweets,
twitter accounts,
and a lot of really interesting people
that post interesting stuff.
But you gotta know how to abandon a
tweet.
Several words in like,
this is bullshit.
I'm not reading that.
No,
Oh,
what can they do now?
Teeth are too long.
This is crazy.
No,
it's not even that.
It's just knowing that it's going to be
horse shit.
This is going to be just either gossip
or nonsense or not interesting,
but there's still a shit ton of really
useful information that you can get out
of twitter on a daily basis.
There's always something new that's
coming out and I try to retweet those
things as much as possible.
When I see something that someone sends
me and then that becomes,
people know,
hey,
if you send joe something really cool
and he reads it,
if I get a chance to read it,
I'll retweet it and people get a kick
out of that so they'll send me more cool
stuff and so then it's sort of.
It's sort of becomes a like a little
ecosystem almost for disseminating
interesting ideas.
Yeah.
That's also bullshit too.
There's a lot of bullshit in there,
a lot,
a lot of arguing,
which I don't do.
I just don't argue.
I think it's a very ineffective way to
communicate with people,
with going back and forth with stuff
like that online.
It just doesn't work well.
It's.
And it becomes,
I think,
more like idea sport with a lot of folks
like they're just trying to win these
little battles and find the whittier
nasty thing to say and it's just,
it's not productive.
It's not healthy.
I don't like it.
Well,
they're doing the same thing that
journalists do,
which is that you get more attention for
doing the wrong thing than you do for
saying the right thing and we all know
that feeling where someone says
something about you that's unfair and
wrong,
and you want to say,
Hey,
wait a second about that.
That is totally incorrect.
I'm going to set the record straight.
And that's what gets the engagement.
Not the kind thoughtful,
considerate thing that somebody says,
yeah,
yes.
I would love to accentuate the trend of
kindness.
I really think that that is one thing,
if there's any one trend and to lean
towards kindness to just to just to be
nicer to people and if we could all sort
of agree that this is a virtue worth
pursuing,
I think it would change the way human
beings interact with each other.
These shifts like the shift of looking
at your phone,
if we could figure out a shift and one
of the more disturbing things to me that
comes from the left,
which I've always associated myself with
being a left leaning person that there's
a lot of meanness coming from the left
now and a lot of lot of by any means
necessary.
A lot of feeling the need to squash
people and humiliate people and insult
people because they agree with what you
believe and that this.
This is a.
I think this is a terrible path to go
down because then it sort of justifies
people who think the opposite of that to
be mean to you.
So now no one's getting anything done
because this side's being insulting and
that side's being insulting and people
are getting kicked out of restaurants
and people are protesting in front of
people's houses because they disagree
with things and he says a lot of
cruelty.
A lot of like meanness and cruelty,
which is the enemy of discourse.
As soon as that stuff gets thrown about
and soon as it becomes a war and idea of
war or an idea sport,
people are just trying to win and the
trying to get back at you for what you
said and you get back at them for that
and it becomes this terrible stall out
situation.
Yeah,
we've all bought into a game and it's a
bad game to play.
It's the worst possible game and it's
very transparent.
I mean you look at what shows up on the
first page of twitter and it's things
that are perfectly designed to generate
opinions.
So teacher says that now classrooms will
be equipped with a bucket of stones to
throw at a school shooter and what do
you feel?
Oh,
that's stupid.
Or Hey,
that's actually kind of a good idea.
It's better than nothing and everyone's
engaging with it and you're buying into
it.
You're supporting it and you're
promoting it and you're making it bigger
by paying attention to it.
I mean,
there's an amazing book that I recommend
anyone listening to this read called
amusing ourselves to death by Neil
Postman,
which he wrote in 1985 before computers,
before social media,
before any of this.
He predicts all of it perfectly without
even knowing the faintest hint of what
was going to happen and you know his
solution if there is one,
is you know partially to disengage from
all of this,
but to try to appreciate long,
nuanced,
careful things which is very hard to
achieve on twitter or
television or most places will try our
best.
Well,
I think that's one of the reasons why
podcasts like especially ones like this
that are these long form conversations
are becoming popular because people are
hungry for actual communication and
they're hungry for people that are just.
Even if we disagree on things.
I want to know why you think the way you
think and I want to hear it all.
I want to hear all of your reasoning.
I want to hear the thought process that
led you to that.
I want to hear that and I want to be
able to talk to you about how I think
and why I think the way I think and
maybe we can come to some middle ground
or at least understand each other and
go,
oh,
I've seen where you went,
or I see why you do.
I see what's happening inside your mind
or the way you feel or how it relates to
your life.
This is absent in most discourse on
television.
It's absent in all talk shows.
It's like what we're talking about,
the oddness of a panel show.
I mean,
they're so bizarre.
It doesn't make any sense.
None of it.
It's not how human beings interact with
each other.
Can you imagine if every conversation
you had in your life there was an
audience clapping or we'll wing at
everything said you'd mean it creates
this sort of fake way of communication
that has become so commonplace with us.
You just.
Even the way they sit sitting next to
each other like this,
like we're not looking at each other.
I would be sitting over here and you'd
be at the desk and I build,
well,
Hamilton,
funny you bring that up,
but you know,
look at the crowd.
It's just,
it's,
it's alien.
It's really weird and I think because of
the fact that people are so addicted to
their phones and addicted to media and
this constant influx of this loop of
information.
I mean if you watch the news,
they can't just give you the fucking
news.
You have to get that scroll on the
bottom of other shit that you should be
freaking out about.
It's like the news itself is not enough.
No.
You have to know about terrorist attacks
and fucking Isis and new,
some new flu that can't be cured and
it's all scrolling on the bottom while
you're watching other shit.
We was.
This is not how human beings are
designed.
We're designed to talk or designed to
communicate with each other person to
person.
This is what we're good at.
This is what we've lost,
and the one thing that has probably lead
to more people understanding more about
each other.
Actual conversations is rare,
which is really weird.
You're,
it's way more common for someone to look
at their phone for 10 hours a day that
it is for someone to have a one-on-one,
uninterrupted conversation with someone
for an hour.
Those don't exist.
They don't exist with lovers.
That's it.
With lovers and occasionally with if you
have polite dinner companions that put
their phone down and just drink a glass
of wine and talk to you about stuff,
but even then people suck at it.
It's almost like people forgot how to do
it.
They talk over each other.
They don't listen to each other.
When the other person's talking,
they just waiting their turn and talk.
It's a we're.
We're going down weird roads that these
roads where we're sort of distancing
ourselves from compassion and
understanding and real communication.
Absolutely.
I don't know what to do about it either.
Psychedelics might help.
That's what I'm saying.
I think they would help.
I think if we had like real centers
where you could go and just like you
could go to a place where you can get a
licensed therapist to massage you.
You know,
hey,
I've gotten this back pole and you know,
the only thing that works is deep tissue
massage.
You go to a place,
they give you a robe,
they played nice music that give you
team and they're.
They're setting the set and see the
setting and the the,
the,
the ambience of the room,
it,
it enhances the experience of getting
the massage.
When you go into the room,
the lights are down.
They might have a candle lit,
you know there's some fucking hot rocks
in the place and they're playing
beautiful harp music in the background.
The set and setting is a part of the
experience of getting a massage.
If we could have something like that and
have these things common for the use of
psychedelics where you could go to a,
a,
an actual,
some sort of therapist that's trained in
both psychotherapy,
in the use of psychedelics so they could
talk to you and find out if you're
stable,
ask you questions about your medical
history,
what kind of medications or you're on
it,
how you feeling,
what are you trying to achieve through
this and then work you through.
An experience,
I think this can be enormously
beneficial.
I'm sure it already has been.
I mean,
that's you.
We keep talking about psychedelic
medicine all the time,
but so much of this has been done.
That's the really crazy thing.
I became used to be a pharmaceutical and
France.
Although as using lower doses that
weren't psychedelic,
there used to be an mdms.
Are they using it for as like a tonic to
stimulate people?
It was called Lam,
Berean,
eight milligram tablets.
What is an effective dose threshold
psychoactivity in my experiences,
about 20 milligrams of the hydrochloride
salt,
but there were microdosing there.
There were many microdosing,
microdosing,
Ibogaine.
They may have used multiple tablets.
I don't know if anyone is familiar with
French historical literature relating to
Ibogaine.
I have a little bit of it,
but there isn't much.
I mean,
again,
they used to use a psychedelic called
Indo pan as an antidepressant and the
Soviet Union in the United States,
there was a drug called Monet's Alpha.
Ethel tryptamine was used as an
antidepressant.
It's an MDM type,
serotonin releaser.
And then of course,
the whole history of dpt facilitated,
um,
end of life therapy,
lsd,
psychotherapy,
and on,
and on it,
everything shoguns group did using two
CB MMDA Ibogaine.
Um,
this was along with Claudio Naranjo in
order to facilitate psychotherapy.
I mean,
people not only were doing it,
they were exploring all the different
ways to do it,
which compounds are best for which
applications.
Hm.
Do you have any experience with cacao?
Yes.
What is your experience in terms of the
psychedelic effects or psychoactive
effects?
Um,
it's mildly stimulating because of the
theobromine content.
But does it mirror a small dose of Mtma
or not?
In my experience,
no,
it was kyle that was talking about that,
right?
Carl Kingsburg,
he was saying that in large doses that
rock cow has some sort of a mild mtma
like effect.
I've heard people say that and people
will sometimes say that the presence of
fin ethylamine in Cacao could account
for that,
but it's such a small amount.
Race quantity is less than a milligram.
And the active dose of Finesse woman is
hundreds of kilograms or grams in order
to achieve a psychoactive effect.
So I think the effect that people do
experience is probably mediated by
theobromine,
which is present in,
in a relatively high quantities.
That's how the,
you know,
it's named after the genus Theobroma
and theobromine does what,
how does it make you feel?
It's a,
it's a caffeine type stimulant.
So when people say that chocolate
contains caffeine,
what they're really referring to
theobromine.
And is that why it's deadly to dogs?
Yes it is.
Huh?
So it's theobromine that's doing it.
Yup.
Fascinating.
So it's not actually caffeine.
No caffeine like substance.
It's less potent than coffee.
And what was your experience like
physically?
How did you feel when you took this?
Uh,
this Cacao and whatnot?
What,
how,
what,
how large dose?
I mean I used to eat it every day.
What?
Raw powders?
The powder you did everyday and yogurt
and I'm just as a health thing.
Yeah,
as a health thing.
And I liked the flavor of it,
but I have never had an experience
beyond,
at most a low level stimulant
experience.
And I've also taken pure theobromine and
is stimulating,
but it requires 500 milligrams to
achieve an effect.
If I remember correctly,
um,
what other,
what about,
um,
you ever fuck with nutmeg?
Nobody.
I mean,
it's a fascinating area.
Um,
of course,
you know,
prisoners historically did it.
Malcolm x did it and the essential oil
of nutmeg contains Marista seven,
which is a precursor for the psychedelic
amphetamine MMDA,
not Mtma,
but it's methoxy,
MDA,
and as well as lme sin,
which is another psychedelic precursor
as well as,
um,
there's,
I think one other maybe even sap role.
Actually,
I think it's saffron.
Lms and Morrison and Shogun had a
hypothesis.
Again,
Shogun was actually by training a
biochemist,
not an organic chemist,
although he spent his career doing
organic chemistry.
So he was very interested in these ideas
with the body creating psychedelics.
So he thought when you consume nutmeg
oil that your body is,
is emanating this double bond and
creating a series of different
amphetamines and that's what accounts
for the high.
But in reality people don't actually
know.
Wow.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So what kind of history of use the does
it have in terms of like people taking
it for the psychoactive benefits?
I'm sure there is some ancient.
You or I would be,
I would assume there is some ancient use
of it,
but um,
you know,
it's mostly like a thing for teenagers
and people in prison these days.
It's kind of,
it's illegal high.
It's one of these things that you do
when you don't have access to,
to anything else and most of the reports
make it sound more like an
anticholinergic delirium type
experience.
More like taking a lot of drama mean
then that like a classical psychedelic
experience,
but you can use that oil to make a lot
of psychedelics in a laboratory.
Wow.
Now,
history of use as well also,
so fascinating me when you talk about
history of use because um,
there are certain cultures that really
don't have a written history.
They have oral history.
So it's very difficult to determine when
people started.
What about
pod?
What is the history of use of peo?
Because I remember reading something
that kind of stunned me that said that
there's only like a couple hundred years
have known use of pod.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
So there's different histories because
pot is used,
it grows naturally over a relatively
broad region.
Stretching from the southern United
States into,
I believe mostly northern Mexico.
And so in the United States,
the history is about 100 years old of
the native American church is its
recent.
Um,
but that's crazy.
So 19,
18,
something like that.
Yes.
It was a,
uh,
a comanche chief named Quanah Parker,
um,
who spread the pod religion across the
United States and it caught on because
it's fantastic.
Of course it caught on.
I've never experienced it.
What is it like,
um,
well again,
it's another one of these plants that
has masculine of course,
but then it has these other accessory
alkaloids that modulate the experience.
So what's really interesting about pod
is it contains this chemical called peo
teen and Payoti and I have some,
uh,
pharmacy trade journals from like 1890
or something like that.
Know maybe it must be later than that.
It must be maybe like 1915 or something
like that sometime around there.
And they talk about like,
your pharmacy must have morphine,
cocaine and peo team,
the three substances every pharmacist
needs and uh,
and pot.
And was used as a hypnotic.
It was used to induce sleep,
but there's been no very little research
on it.
None of the 21st century.
I mean,
this is like a,
it was once considered a really valuable
medicine.
The issues that it's a little bit tricky
to synthesize and it has to be extracted
from this rare cactus Luftwaffe for a
diffuser.
But,
um,
but that modulates the experience.
You have so many different alkaloids and
um,
and it,
it's very long lasting.
It causes dramatic pupil dilation.
It's extremely nauseated and bomb.
I made an episode about pod in the most
recent season of my show,
um,
and I vomited so much that my nose
started bleeding.
Um,
you know,
it was some serious vomiting and it's
physically very,
very punishing,
more so than almost anything I've ever
done.
I would in terms of the aftereffects or
while you're doing it while you're doing
it,
it's a heavy load on the body.
So it's.
People always say this is not
recreational or whatever,
but it's truly as NC,
you know,
this is really,
um,
a punishing experience.
And on top of that,
the native American ceremonies often
accentuate some of those punishing
aspects of it,
like water is conserved.
You don't get to drink as much water as
you want to emphasize the importance of
water in Mazda Tech,
Salvia ceremonies,
there's no water at all,
which I think is actually increases the
absorption of the leaf into your mouth
because the natural reaction when you
eat something disgusting is to wash it
down with water.
These are little things that people do
impulsively without thinking that are
going to change the nature of the
experience.
So anyway,
you eat this cactus,
it's incredibly nauseated and bitter.
And then you have maybe a 12 hour,
um,
hallucinatory euphoric state that's very
beautiful and strange.
But you see the cactus raw.
Yeah.
Some people grind it,
some people cook it.
So you could get that shit at home
depot,
you can get San Pedro at home depot.
No,
no pod is a dumpling cactus.
It's a very small,
um,
somewhat spherincel cactus that produces
beautiful white and pink flowers.
And it's incredibly slow growing,
which is why the conservation of Pod is
an even bigger issue in the conservation
of toads pod.
All these psychedelic plants have major
conservation issues that need to be
addressed,
but pod is arguably the biggest of them
all because this is a slow growing
plant.
If you want to learn patience,
grow pot,
that is how you learn.
I mean,
this,
this bottle cap,
I mean,
it takes five years before it's the size
of a dime if you grow it from seed.
So when you're eating something that's,
you know,
um,
that's as big as the room of a coffee
mug or something like that might be 20,
30 years old Jesus Christ.
So there's a lot of history in these
plants.
They call them grandfather pod.
And I think the reason is that by the
time that they're ready to be consumed,
they often,
our grandfathers or grandmothers,
they have produce seeds and have
offspring and all of this stuff because
it takes that long.
Um,
so yes,
it's very slow growing.
It's not a sustainable practice the way
that it's being done.
But there's also even bigger threats to
the environment in the form of root
plowing,
all the territory to build walmarts and
subdivisions and different things in
south Texas because most of that land is
privately owned and um,
and it's difficult because there's a
belief in the native American church
that has to be an outdoor natural grown.
It can't be a greenhouse cultivated
plant the because part of the potency
and the value is from his interaction
with nature.
So it's,
it's if it's sustainably harvested,
where only the crown of the cactus is
removed,
but this long carrot like taproot is
left in the soil.
It can regenerate new heads.
But if people don't have proper
harvesting techniques,
it can decimate the population very
quickly,
especially because it's not a very
potent substance.
Requires many of these ultra,
ultra,
ultra slow growing plants.
Wow.
So what is the natural territory of it?
How wide is the natural territory of
these plants?
I can't tell you exactly,
but it's not very large.
So if it got very popular,
that'd be a real problem yet it probably
won't.
I mean,
you know,
the people that care most about it
outside of the native American church
are interestingly cactus files and
Thailand and Japan who grow it for
purely aesthetic purposes because it's
so beautiful.
They and they would never even consider
it because to them it's this prized
ornamental plant that produces amazing
fruit and flowers and lives seemingly
forever.
And if you take care of it,
it can just look amazing.
So,
um,
those,
there's a huge pod scene in Thailand of
people that never would dream of
consuming it,
that just grow it ornamental.
Wow.
Now San Pedro Cactus,
does that have psychoactive properties?
Absolutely,
yes.
And did you have to extract it in a
different way?
I'm like,
God,
it can be consumed raw.
Um,
the,
with some varieties of San Pedro,
they actually contain comparable
quantities of masculine to pod and it's
a much more sustainable source of
masculine for that reason.
And Crows,
unlike pod,
it grows very,
very quickly and um,
and can be propagated by cutting easily
and it,
you know,
it's much easier to work with.
Um,
but traditionally if you go to Peru,
they'll take a length of the cactus and
they'll cut it like a loaf of bread into
slices.
Then they boil the slices and create a
sort of low potency aqueous infusion
that they drink.
And what's interesting about the way
they do it is that it seems that it's
almost designed to create a lower
potency drink the way they do it.
They drink every night,
the Shamans,
every night of their entire life.
And many people come back and do it
repeatedly.
And for them it's sort of,
it's like a traditional form of
microdosing you could say.
It's not about blasting herself into the
cosmos the way people do when they
smoke.
DMT.
This is about fortifying your body,
giving yourself strength,
cleansing yourself,
balancing yourself and other people that
consume it as well.
Not that I saw there.
No.
Hmm.
Oh,
but people do.
What people do I have.
And what is the effect?
Is it comparable to the pod effect?
It's comparable,
but it's,
yeah,
it's comparable,
but again,
it gets very hard because of these
variations with natural products in
terms of the potency of the cactus and
that point in your life and you know,
people will always come up to me and
say,
what's the deal with Mtma?
It used to be like this and now it's
like this.
What accounts for that?
And it's like,
well,
don't underestimate your own changes
over time.
When I was 21,
I could drink alcohol,
not that I did very often,
but I could and not want to kill myself
the next day.
Now if I try to drink more than three
drinks,
I'm going to feel horrible the next day.
Like just emotionally ruined.
And that's me,
not alcohol.
Now you brought up the term a hypnotic
and which made me reminded,
reminded me of our conversation that we
had through email about Roseanne Barr.
Oh yeah.
Oh yes,
of course.
Yes.
And about Ambien and about the effects
of Ambien.
She came on the show.
She still hasn't.
She can't.
She's having a really hard time with
this.
Um,
she feels terrible about what she said.
She feels like the whole world hates
her.
She feels like she's lost everything and
her life is destroyed and she's
distraught and she,
she was going to fly out here,
but we had a conversation and we kind of
decided to be probably better if she
waited,
just let,
let some of this
pass by.
It's still in the news because they've
decided to move the show on without her
there.
They're going to kill her off or
something.
Yeah.
And she's just devastated and uh,
you know,
she was also devastated health wise.
Physically she's an older woman and not
that it'd be any different.
She was an older man.
She's an older person and this grueling
schedule of doing a television show was
horrible on her.
It just,
it was really,
really tough to do.
She got bronchitis.
She felt like she was almost dying.
She was completely exhausted and she
felt like the schedule of it all just
was just way too taxing on her
physically.
Then on top of that,
she's on a host of different things.
She's,
I mean,
she'll ever do wind up sitting down and
talking on the podcast.
I'll get her to,
to list the various thing she's on,
but she's on various antidepressants.
She changes them up,
mixes them mob.
She was one of the things she said to
me,
she's,
she needs to get her doses readjusted.
She drinks alcohol regularly,
she smokes marijuana regularly.
She's also an Ambien,
regularly takes it every night to go to
sleep.
And I tried to explain to her the fact
that you're not getting real sleep when
you're on that this is not something you
should take and rely on on a daily
basis.
They even tell you to get off of it.
I mean,
it's,
and it's difficult to get off of it.
Um,
but people want to dismiss the idea that
she could have said something that's
completely out of character or done
something that's completely out of
character while under the influence of
this stuff that it could have
contributed to that.
They want to dismiss it because they
want a villain they want,
oh no,
she's bad.
They want this,
like this childlike simplistic reasoning
and rationalization.
For what she's done,
right,
and this is,
you know,
prime example of this sort of
schizophrenia nature of the way drugs
are depicted in our society.
If it's,
if it's something like bath salts or k
two,
they're responsible for everything.
One toke of that stuff and you're eating
your best friend's face under a bridge,
but then in case they have no
explanation whatsoever,
no exculpatory value,
they can't be used to explain anything.
Is it an excuse?
No.
Is it an explanation?
I think yes.
I think that intoxication can explain
all sorts of inappropriate behavior and
to pretend otherwise is.
Again,
dishonest.
I know am Sanofi the pharmaceutical
company that manufactures ambien had
this widely shared tweet saying that
racism isn't a side effect of Ambien,
but it's a little bit ridiculous for
them to have done that.
You know,
especially to someone who's mentally ill
because,
you know,
if you look at the medical literature,
the fact of the matter is that ambient
is associated with all sorts of absurd
behaviors.
Command hallucinations where people stab
themselves,
jump out windows,
people that you know,
butter their cigarettes and smoke them.
People that paint their houses in the
middle of the night with no memory
whatsoever,
and it's a profoundly,
profoundly disinhibiting drug.
So,
you know,
here,
here's maybe a somewhat analogous
example from my own life.
I never take ambien on planes for this
reason because I'm around strangers.
I don't know what I'm going to say or
what I'm going to do,
let alone use twitter,
but I don't.
It's uncomfortable because it's so
disinhibiting.
I might do something weird.
I don't know.
Take off my shirt.
I have no idea.
You who's to predict what you're going
to do when you have no inhibitions
whatsoever.
So I remember once I was on the plane to
Berlin and I did take ambien and I start
in this sort of delusional state
thinking that the cabin crew and the
person that's announcing over the
entercom is saying various Nazi things.
That's like an unfair stereotype that
all Germans are Nazis that's offensive,
but I had no control over this.
Just because they're German talking in
German doesn't mean that this is like a
Nazi airship because you're just
completely out of your mind.
Wow.
But again,
I mean,
like another story,
um,
I used to be friends with a girl whose
dad was a psychiatrist,
prescribes her immense quantities of
Ambien and um,
she would snort it.
There's no reason to start it.
It's water soluble.
It has a fast onset of action.
There's no benefit and snorting it,
it's fine orally if you're going to take
it at all.
And there's no reason to take high
doses.
It's already a delirium at the
therapeutic dose.
You don't need to take more,
even five milligrams induces delirium.
But,
um,
but I remember I was at some party and
someone was saying that they wanted
ketamine,
did anyone at the party of ketamine and
just a complete stranger.
And I said,
Oh,
I actually have a little bit of ketamine
but it's at my apartment,
here are the keys and here's my address
and just run over to my apartment and,
and help yourself talk to you later.
And uh,
and then,
um,
I,
I'm one of these people,
I've never lost my phone,
never lost my keys.
I don't lose things.
So then I,
you know,
wake up the next morning,
go to my apartment,
reached into my pocket,
my keys are gone,
and then it hits me this flash of,
oh my God,
I gave my keys away to a complete
stranger to go to my apartment and take
ketamine from me.
What on earth was I thinking?
What?
Like what level of disinhibition is
required to do something that insane.
Luckily I was there.
I had to spend the rest of the day
tracing,
finding out who that person was getting
my keys and these people happen to be
very courteous people and actually did
go to my apartment,
did take the small amount of ketamine
that I had and then just lock the door
after themselves and didn't make a mess.
But again,
I mean this is like,
this is a profoundly disinhibiting
substance.
And also I think the idea that a drug
couldn't modulate racist activities.
Interesting as well because there's a
study that you can look up where they
use the Beta blocker,
propranolol and they found that it
actually seems to block racial implicit
racial bias in people in certain tests
that what they're suggesting is that
there's an address,
energetic component to implicit racial
bias,
but there's a certain maybe heart rate
or fear response and once the
physiologically blocked you become less
racist in a sense implicitly.
It's not a conscious decision.
Conscious racism isn't reduced,
but an implicit racial bias is.
I mean these are like really complicated
higher level questions about how drugs
impact cognitive functioning and um,
and the bottom line I think is be
careful being certain about anything
about what drugs can or can't do.
What does this Jamie.
Oh,
this is the story.
Blood pressure drug reduces inbuilt.
What does that word in built?
Racism.
Common heart disease drug may have an
unusual side effect of combating racism.
Wasn't that a fucking.
There was that stupid movie with Jack
Nicholson and Helen Hunt is good as it
gets.
He was a racist and they gave him a
pill.
They gave him some medication and it
reduced racism.
It stopped him from being racist.
Whoa.
I completely forgot about.
I remember it because I was angry
because a bunch of people from the the.
I was working on television show at the
time.
A bunch of people were talking about how
great a movie it was because it was this
weird dark sort of film and I was like,
that movie fucking sucked.
It was so depressing.
Here.
This woman,
she's got a.
she's a waitress and Jack Nicholson is
this old racist asshole and she's
relying on him for some real reason
because you can't find anyone who's nice
to her and and he's racist,
but the,
the,
the resolve of the film was that he just
was sick and they gave him some
medication.
He wasn't racing anymore.
I'm like,
get the fuck out of here.
That doesn't make any sense.
Meanwhile,
maybe it does.
I mean,
ambient is an amazing,
amazing substance.
I made a piece about it called the
ambient effect years ago.
I don't know if you're familiar.
They're people who are paralyzed who can
take ambien and start walking again.
It has the power to regenerate regions
of the to regenerate activity in regions
of the brain that looked dead on Fmr.
Try
it is a wacky drug.
It's also chemically very similar to
five methyl dmt.
It's,
it's not,
it's not like a benzodiazepine like
valium.
It has its own bizarre structure.
I mean,
it's a weird drug.
So when these people are paralyzed by
the paralyzed,
like what?
What is wrong with the strokes?
Traumatic brain injury,
various reasons.
There's a book about it called hope and
brain damage.
I believe the title of it is an Ambien
somehow or another temporarily fixes it.
Yes.
Temper only for the duration of the drug
effects.
So those people that are in a persistent
vegetative state,
they take ambien and suddenly they wake
up.
What the fuck?
Yes.
Yeah.
It's pretty.
It's well documented and it's a really
bizarre effect that is exclusively
present in ambient and maybe slightly
and um,
Baclifin as well.
Yeah.
I thought that the statement that the
pharmaceutical company made about a
racism not being a side effect was kind
of cute.
It's kind of witty.
It was a very snarky.
Yes.
But the problem with that shit is,
well,
what are the side effects?
And then you go into the actual side
effects and like,
Holy Shit,
how is this legal?
And then you go into the side effects of
like,
what is this doing to people like,
well here's another one.
It supposedly increases consolidation of
negative memories.
Whoa.
Yeah.
There's a lot of weird stuff.
Negative memory increases.
Consolidation of negative memories
causes a just total hallucinatory
insanity at higher doses.
Maybe the most powerful disinhibiting
agent I'm aware of and is able to
restore cognitive and motor functioning
and people with traumatic brain
injuries.
What a weird drug.
Very weird.
And not not something people should be
taking every day.
Just not.
It's certainly addictive.
I mean it binds to,
even though it's not a benzodiazepine
itself,
it binds to the benzodiazepine site on
the Gaba a receptor.
But yes,
no,
it's addictive.
It's super addictive.
So for that reason alone,
people shouldn't be taking it every day
because you'll become horrendously
dependent on it.
And withdrawal is ruthless.
The etsy,
the withdrawal is total insomnia.
So most people just go right back to it
or you know,
you can then track,
like you can transition onto different
types of hypnotics,
like taking an anticholinergic,
like Benadryl to sleep or cannabinoids
cannabis,
things like that,
or um,
you know,
just things that don't buy into the Gaba
a receptor in order to try to reduce
tolerance.
There's ways around it.
You're not doomed if you start taking
it,
but it's,
it's certainly,
um,
habit forming and something that's best
to avoid if you don't require it and it
doesn't give you real sleep.
Correct.
I mean,
you're,
you're missing some part of the sleep
cycle with Dr Matthew Walker was on,
here's a sleep specialist and he went
into depth about it,
but I really don't remember his exact
description,
but he was talking about how it bypasses
certain cycles and you're,
you're not getting a real night's sleep.
I am not aware of that.
I mean,
there's,
wouldn't surprise me hugely.
You know,
there's still debate about what the most
restful part of sleep is.
Um,
I think most literature points to
actually non rem sleep,
slow wave sleep being the most restful
type.
And that's actually supported or
promoted by chemicals like Musk Amal
from the m and e to miscarry a mushroom
that,
that in,
and there was one pharmaceutical
derivative called gearbox at all that I
did an episode about on the most recent
season of my show.
And that really does produce incredibly
restful sleep that is superior to
ambient.
But like ambient,
it was also psychedelic,
even more psychedelic probably.
So this is an issue.
It seems it for whatever reason,
a lot of these drugs that really promote
sleep effectively also happened to be
hallucinogenic and nobody knows exactly
why,
but it's been a pharmaceutical barrier
because we don't live in a culture that
allows people to go nuts at night.
Yeah,
no kidding.
I'm glad you brought up the mud to
miscarrying because that's another one.
Um,
that is,
uh,
almost like a drug of lore more than a
drug of application.
You don't really hear too much about
people getting real good experiences.
No you don't.
But it's also connected to a sacred
mushroom and the cross,
the cover of it from John,
mark or allegro has an emmy nominated
Mascara.
He thought that the emanated Ms Dot
Garcia was probably linked to
psychedelic states and pre historic
Christianity.
We,
we don't know.
Right.
Oh,
he's such a salacious wacky guy.
Mazy oh yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
he,
he was getting off on it.
He loved it.
He will love getting off on freaking
people out.
Freaking out.
Christian.
That was a.
You can't underestimate what he was
saying.
He was saying all of Christianity is a
sex cult that worships a fungal Phallus
and the semen of that Phallus or the
spores.
Yeah.
Then all of Christianity is an ancient
fertility called.
That's a big claim from a serious Oxford
educated Dead Sea scrolls scholar who is
respected up until that point.
Yeah.
Who was also an ordained minister.
I mean there's a great book called
shroom that argues that this was all,
some kind of cynical attack on the
Christian religion and that,
uh,
he didn't even believe it himself.
I'm.
The issue is that in order to carefully
examine his claims,
you need to speak what is it?
Ancient Aramaic or something.
So it's like,
it doesn't,
I'm not in a position reading his book,
which is all having to do with the
etymology of these words,
their origins in different languages.
I just don't know enough about these
ancient languages to make a,
an informed assessment
of his claims.
But uh,
which is I think one reason that they've
kind of hung around in this lower for
such a long time because it's hard for
people to say with certainty,
um,
if they're true or not.
Although I leaned to them for them
probably not being well supported.
They pause.
Why is that?
Um,
just seems to be wacky.
Yeah.
Because they're not.
I haven't seen them integrated into any
serious work since I'm not that that's
necessarily a good argument.
Yes.
To take on a lot of education to be able
to even understand whether or not that
debate is
cogent.
Right,
right.
It's the same deal.
I encountered this sometimes on really
fringe aspects of physics and chemistry
where someone will make some kind of
wacky argument about the way atoms bond
or something like that.
And it's like,
it gets hard because you only have like
a small handful of people that are
capable of seriously evaluating the
claims,
able to weigh in and then it doesn't
really get vetted in a serious way.
So things just linger around is,
maybe it's true,
maybe it's not,
but um,
but the bottom line is that most people
don't get it a valuable experience from
these mushrooms,
but some do,
some people have figured out how to make
it work and the experiences,
again,
it's,
you know,
it's its own thing.
It's a gabaergic delirium to takes you
into a dreamy drunk zone.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's in many ways a toxin,
right?
It's toxic in some forums.
Well,
it contains a,
another chemical in botanic acid that is
potentially very toxic,
although it hasn't really been examined.
In fact,
it also contains a complex of this
element vanadium that could potentially
be toxic as well.
So there are some legitimate toxicity
concerns that I think anyone who's
consuming it should be aware of.
Um,
you know,
the ideal situation would be isolated
Moscow mall,
but it's hard to extract.
Hm.
And but yet it's connected in so much
artwork and so,
so much ancient depictions of
particularly of Christmas cards.
There's always elves and these little
laminated miscarried caps.
Right.
Well,
drugs aside,
you have to acknowledge that it's a
spectacularly beautiful mushrooms if
you.
I've gotten mushroom hunting all over
the world and there is no question that
when you see that mushroom in habitat
that it's
completely spectacular.
There's nothing else like it.
It is magical experience.
Just looking at it.
Yeah.
I ran across it only once in Colorado in
the woods and it was amazing.
It's like this big.
It was a big one too,
is this big,
beautiful red with white dots on it.
It's like one of the most gorgeous
things you could ever see growing.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And it's legal.
It's legal to possess again.
Yes.
It's legal because it's not really do
anything enjoyable for most people,
but is it possible that we just are
doing it wrong and that the,
the information
has been lost as to how to.
Because a lot of people felt like it
might've been a part of Soma,
which hasn't really been defined as to
what Soma is,
right?
We had those debates are not really my,
uh,
my cup of tea,
right.
It's like just tons of guys pushing this
or that argument without like a lot of
evidence one way or the other.
And so I don't know.
And then there's people that argue that
urine drinking is somehow required to
concentrate the muskeg mall in one way
or another.
Um,
you know,
if you want to learn about it,
I think the best way to do it is
actually through this other related
drug.
Got Box at all,
which was,
um,
almost developed by merck as a
competitor for Ambien.
And there's some high dose reports of
gearbox and all that gives you a much
clearer example.
And from my own experience as well,
of what the potential of that class is.
And it's very different.
It's every bit as powerful as Iowasca or
something like that.
But completely different.
And it's hard to articulate.
All these things are hard to articulate,
but it's something that's been
experienced by relatively few people so
that you don't even have this a
spiritual or metaphorical vocabulary for
it.
The way that I hadn't most powerfully
was once I was doing a shoot for vice on
Hbo and they told me I had to go to
Tokyo with less than 24 hours notice and
that I had to start filming as soon as
the plane landed,
couldn't go to the hotel room.
So I thought,
all right,
this is serious.
No messing around.
No time for jet lag.
Like I've got to fall asleep at 10:00
PM that night.
Wake up at 8:00
AM that morning.
I've got to be awake all day,
so I'm in a pharmacologically forced
this a little bit.
I'm going to take a really high dose of
this mosquito old derivative at night to
induce sleep and I'll take adderall
during the day.
That was the plan,
so I took a high dose,
I believe it was 45 milligrams,
but don't quote me on that.
Of this musket mule derivative.
It's about the same potency and I'm at
the equivalent of what would have been
maybe 2:00
PM New York time,
which I think was crucial because these
things are hypnotic.
They induce sleep.
So if you take it during the day,
you're less likely to sleep through the
whole experience.
And it was unbelievable.
I mean,
I,
uh,
I couldn't fathom the intensity of what
I experienced.
It was,
you know,
just this rushing sense of,
of becoming a passive observer in my own
consciousness and seeing all of my
thoughts produced by someone else that
we're racing at a speed that was so fast
that I found it physically dizzying and
had to lay down.
And I felt as if like the acceleration
was pushing me toward an ultimate state
that was sleep and that sleep in death
represented the ultimate state of
consciousness.
Whoa.
So it was,
it was,
and then,
you know,
then I had to wake up at eight and work
the next day and people say,
how'd you sleep?
And it's like,
well,
I actually had this,
uh,
a transformative existential trip
accidentally.
But you tried it since?
Just purposely for,
I mean a couple of times.
Yeah.
Did you ever recreate that kind of
experience?
No,
because it was,
it was a bit much I would say,
and I know people that have taken even
more and it turns into just your entire
visual field,
a transforming into rotating cubes where
each face of the cube represents a
different aspect of your life,
your future,
your past,
your present,
you know,
really dramatic stuff.
So I think that potential exists with
high dose Moscow mule.
It's hard for people to ingest it
because of all the other material in the
mushroom and the disgustingness of
consuming it.
So is it possible that we've just much
like people have sort of a altered many
different things like we and tomatoes
and what have you that at one point in
time the mushrooms somehow different?
Oh yeah.
Well yes,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the evolutionary chemical history of all
these different plants is a fascinating
subject that's pretty much lost to
history.
You know,
there's no like,
archeological alkaloid analysis that I'm
aware of,
but it would be so fascinating to know
because all of these natural products
evolve,
just like the plants that contain them.
What were the intermediate materials?
What drugs have gone extinct have,
did our ancestors drive certain
psychoactive plants to extinction?
There's a plant called psyllium that
some people have argued that may have
happened with those,
a fennel derivative,
um,
or like a fennel related plant.
But,
um,
yeah,
I mean it's,
it's really,
and it,
we've seen it with cannabis,
you know,
the black market encouraged everyone to
produce thc dominant strains because it
was the most potent,
most stoning,
most bang for your buck.
Now,
now we have the ability to change the
evolutionary direction of the plant and
to encourage the production of CBN or
CBG or Hcv or cbd or whatever.
Hm.
So
when you talk about a plant like the pod
cactus that grows so incredibly slow and
you know,
if,
if that became something that was highly
sought after,
very,
very valuable,
it could conceivably be wiped out.
Yes.
Yeah.
Especially something really.
So I'm so there could have been
substances like that,
that we're very geographically local,
that very small area that are just gone.
Yeah.
It's just a thought.
I just had totally done evidence based,
but wouldn't it be crazy if a lot of the
reason that a lot of these,
um,
psychoactive plants that are present
today tend to be less addictive is
because all the addictive ones were
harvested to extinction thousands of
years ago.
Maybe something like that.
I mean,
these things do happen if you didn't
have know.
We really wouldn't have any way of
knowing,
but if there fossilized plants,
right,
right.
It certainly didn't happen with coca,
which contains cocaine or cat.
So it probably didn't happen that way,
but you know,
you just don't know.
Yeah.
And I had read some theories that it's
conceivable that the emoney to miscarry
a very seasonably uh,
so you have to figure out like when is
the right time to harvest?
Because there are some plans.
Although of course fungus isn't really a
plant,
it's kind of the opposite of a plan that
way.
And ingest oxygen,
it takes in carbon,
it takes an oxygen.
And breathe out carbon dioxide like a,
like an animal does,
but that it's possible that these things
vary seasonably,
that you have to catch them within a
window of time and that they also vary
geographically.
Like some places they might be more
potent,
like,
you know,
Cuban cigars,
grown on specific land,
have a distinct,
probably more a more potent taste to
them.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Because the biosynthetic precursors for
all of these natural products come from
the soil.
Typically,
you know,
amino acids and things like that,
and it's all going to change.
There was an amazing experiment that was
done where they started doping the
substrate of psilocybin containing
mushrooms with other tryptamines,
so they used,
instead of the DDT and dip tea,
put it in the substrate and they found
that the mushroom would take that
completely synthetic chemical that does
not occur in nature.
It would then four hydroxylase indole
ring just like it were a silicon
derivative and create natural product
derivatives of these synthetic
materials.
Creating these semi-synthetic hybrids
between men and mushroom creations.
Jesus.
Yeah.
I mean this is like why the synthetic,
natural dichotomy doesn't make sense.
Everything's evolving,
it's a constant interplay between human
and plants and fungus,
you know,
after we're all gone,
all of our plastic bottles are going to
be consumed by some bacterium that
evolves to degrade all of these,
you know,
polymers and that will create natural
products from them and will those
natural products,
because they were derived from the
substrate that we created,
you know,
it turns into like a very complicated
issue,
which is why I don't believe in the idea
of natural and synthetic.
Everything is simultaneously natural and
simultaneously synthetic.
Well,
everything comes from Earth.
Yes.
So even the most unnatural things that
human beings are created are in
essential natural creations.
Like a b creates a beehive of beehives
and natural creation.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a mind fuck.
So to get back to emoney,
to miscarry,
uh,
do,
do you know of anyone who's affectively
regularly used it as a psychedelic?
Yes,
I've met but not people who I wacky
people.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Not.
People where it's like,
oh,
that guy's a professor and he uses Amany
to every night to sleep.
He's doing really?
But,
but yes,
wacky people,
there's so much lower,
again,
a attached to it specifically because
the Christian,
I mean the books by allegro,
we're,
we're big,
right?
One of them was the Dead Sea Scrolls in
the Christian myth and it was one of his
books and that was the second book that
he published after the sacred mushroom
in the cross.
I think he did that because they took
the sacred mushroom and the cross off
the market.
Right.
Like what did the Catholic Church by out
the rights for that?
Or was that a myth as well?
I can't remember.
It was something along those lines,
but Yon Irvin republished it fairly
recently with the blessings of the
allegro family,
but the,
the,
just the whole connection to Santa Claus
and the whole connection to Christmas
with that mushroom,
it's,
there's so much attached to that.
Mushroom people want that mushroom to be
Jesus.
That's the one,
you know,
that's the way it's the prettiest.
It's like it grows.
It's got a Michael Riser relationship
with coniferous trees.
So you find it underneath pine trees,
just like the shiny presence underneath
the Christmas tree.
So people get so excited about that
mushroom.
Yes they do,
but yet no one gets off on it except
wacky people.
Yeah.
It's a complicated situation and you
know,
just because something's convenient
isn't a good reason to say that it's the
truth.
There are other psychoactive mushrooms
that may have been used in the past.
They're ones that we've discovered
recently.
There's a species called Rodo,
Columbia Maculotta,
as far as I know,
that there's no information about humans
consuming this mushroom,
but it contains this Salvinorin,
a type kappa opioid agonist.
This could be a completely different
type of psychedelic mushroom.
No information on it exists.
Maybe someone used it somewhere in the
past.
I don't know.
Whoa.
Well,
isn't there?
There are some psychedelic substances
that have been discovered that have no
history of human use.
Like isn't Hawaiian baby.
Woodrow says,
I,
you say it doesn't have lsd like
properties,
but no history of human use.
Um,
that's a complicated question.
Yeah.
There's maybe not with Hawaiian baby
woodrow is,
but with morning glory seeds,
there does seem to be some mezo American
history,
although it's not as well founded
and morning glory seeds.
We'll put you on the moon,
right?
Well,
they,
yeah,
they contain Lsa and um,
again,
Lsa is actually Albert Hoffman did as
the inventor of Lsd did it and
experiment where he injected himself
with small quantities of Lsa,
but there aren't many evaluations of the
pure material.
So the exact nature of the different
components in those seeds remains a
little bit mysterious as far as I'm
concerned.
Some people will suggest that it's the
strongest,
naturally occurring psychedelic.
Other people will say that it's not even
psychedelic at all,
that it's just a hypnotic.
It just has a sort of sedating quality.
I've used Hawaiian baby wardrobes many,
many years ago and um,
it's certainly psychoactive,
whether I'd call it classically
psychedelic is a complicated issue.
It's of like a dreamy,
unpleasant delirium.
Hm.
Um,
any other ones that we could go to that
are weird.
Watch my show.
I think you'd really like it.
I'm sure I'd like it.
I like all your stuff.
Okay.
Because it goes into lots of weird.
I just don't have enough time.
There's too many things that are cool
now.
Yeah.
That's one of the problems with a
Netflix and hbo and Youtube and just too
much cool stuff,
but this will be cool.
I will definitely watch it.
Okay.
Uh,
that was three hours,
man.
It just flew by.
Well,
not crazy.
That is crazy.
We got have time more over here.
So,
uh,
listen,
this is way better than the first time
we did it.
We were here I think.
Got a lot of cool information now and I
really appreciate you coming back,
man.
Thanks for having me do this again,
but not in seven years to quicker.
Yes,
I hope for sure.
Thank you.
And on twitter and Instagram,
it's Hamilton Morris.
And your show is Hamilton's Pharmacopia.
It's.
Is it available online because people
watch it online?
Yes,
it's on Hulu and streaming on Amazon and
streaming on itunes and it's on vice
land as well.
So yeah,
easy to find.
Thanks man.
That was awesome.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Hmm.